Und damit herzlich willkommen zu einem weiteren Chaos Radio im Blue Moon auf Fritz, das heißt alle zwei Monate reitet hier der Chaos Computer Club ein und erklärt uns etwas über diese digitalen Dinge, die da draußen passieren und das sind heute ganz schön viele Leute, nämlich der Danimo, der Dennis, der Dirk und der Christian. Hallo und guten Abend.
Schönen guten Abend.
Sehr schön und wir wollen heute darüber reden, wie viel Bit ein Euro ist oder wie viel Euro ein Bit wiegt oder so ähnlich. Also wir wollen ein bisschen über Finanzen im Digitalen reden, was so Ideen sind für, wie kann man eigentlich das, ich gebe am Laden-Counter jemanden einen Euroschein oder eine Münze über und wie kann das digital aussehen. Da gibt es schon so ein paar Ansätze. Ihr habt vielleicht schon mal von Bitcoin gehört, da werden wir heute nochmal drüber reden. Es gibt auch ein paar neue Sachen, die da passieren. Es gibt sogenannte Smart Contracts, ganz wilde komplexe Dinge. Und wir fangen aber einfach an und gucken erstmal, was ist denn sozusagen im Angebot für, ich sage mal normalsterbliche. Also ihr seht vielleicht die Werbung von diesem einen großen digitalen Zahlungsanbieter, Paypal, der gerade sagt, ja, ihr könnt jetzt alles über uns machen. Guck mal, was das ist. Und vielleicht habt ihr auch im Laden so diese kleinen EC-Kartengeräte gesehen. Also nicht dieses normale große Ding, sondern so kleine Sachen, die irgendwie mit so einem Würfel, der mit einem Pad verbunden ist. Und wie das funktioniert, ob das sicherer ist oder unsicherer und was da eigentlich so am Start ist, das klären wir alles heute hier. Bevor wir das machen, aber ein aktuelles Thema, das wollen wir noch ganz kurz aufgreifen, weil das etwas ist, wo man sofort auch immer nach dem Chaos Computer Club schreit. Und zwar habt ihr vielleicht in den letzten Tagen gehört vom sogenannten Darknet, der Amokläufer, der Anschlag, der Anschläger in München hat ja seine Waffe angeblich im Darknet gekauft und jetzt ist die Forderung laut, ja man müsse das Darknet vielleicht überwachen oder aufbrechen oder entschlüsseln und das hört sich an wie so, Darknet, was ist das denn eigentlich dieser böse Platz im Internet, wo die Verbrecher, Verbrecher Dinge machen? Genau, das wollen wir jetzt nochmal ganz kurz klären. Und Dirk, du wolltest uns glaube ich erklären, Darknet, was ist das denn eigentlich überhaupt? Was meint das denn?
Ich wollte das erklären, okay.
Ich meine.
Nee, Danimo wollte das eigentlich machen.
Ich hatte noch im Kopf, also Chaosradio heißt nicht umsonst, ich hatte im Kopf, wir kriegen jetzt eine technische Erklärung und dann eine politische Einordnung.
Also, na gut, also so wie ich das Darknet verstehe, sind das anonyme Serverdienste, das heißt, der Server steht irgendwo und ist dann über Tor, das Tor-Netzwerk, erreichbar und nicht über das öffentliche Internet, das heißt, man braucht einen speziellen Client, um in dieses Tor-Netzwerk reinzukommen und dann gibt es auch spezielle Adressen, die auf Punkt Onion enden und die kann man halt nur mit Tor, dem TheOnion-Router erreichen und ja, das ist zumindest das, was ich unter Darknet verstehe.
Okay, also das ist sozusagen im Prinzip auch online, aber...
Das ist ein Overlay-Network, könnte man sagen. Also sowas, was drüber liegt über dem Onion.
Also du, das Internet mit seiner ganz normalen Vermaschung benutzt du eigentlich bei Tor auch. Was du aber zusätzlich tust, ist, du benutzt einen Dienst, sowas, was dein Browser auch verwenden würde. Der gibt dir aber nicht direkt Webseiten, sondern der gibt dir Kontakt in ein Netz, das quasi in dem Internet noch mal drin liegt. Und was das Besondere ist, es gibt dort verschiedene Knoten, über die du in dieses Netz reinkommst, sogenannte Exit-Notes. Und in diesem Netz hast du zwei Prinzipien, die funktionieren. Das eine ist dieses ständige Rumreichen zwischen verschiedenen Servern. Und die andere Komponente ist, dass während des Rumreichens immer noch mal verschlüsselt wird. Und die Idee, dass du, wenn du zwischen verschiedenen Servern rumgereicht wirst und jedes Mal deine Findung noch verschlüsselt ist, ist die Idee, dass derjenige, der am Ende die Seite anbietet, die du dir anguckst, hinterher nicht mehr nachvollziehen kannst, wer du eigentlich bist.
Okay, warte.
Das ist jetzt die normale Nutzung von Tor.
Ich möchte jetzt versuchen, zusammenzufassen. Also im normalen Internet ist es so, ich surfe zu einer Webseite. Und die Webseite, zu der ich surfe, ist auch ein Computer. Und der Betreiber dieses Computers kann normalerweise wissen, wo ich herkomme, weil er meine sogenannte IP-Adresse sieht. Und da kann man dann im Zweifel auch immer nachschlagen, wer ich bin.
Ja, bei Anbietern nachfragen und die müssen dann die Informationen rausgeben.
Genau. Und im Darknet, was ihr Beispiel von Tor beschrieben habt, ist es so, ich kommuniziere auch mit jemandem, also einem Webserver oder irgendwas, aber der weiß gar nicht, wer ich bin.
Genau, dadurch, dass es verschlüsselt und verwürfelt wird, so dass es möglichst verschleiert ist. Es ist also tatsächlich eher eine Verschleierung. Und da kommen wir vielleicht gleich nochmal drauf, warum das Probleme macht.
Nämlich? Ganz kurz, es gibt ein Entry-Node, das ist da, wo dein Tor-Client hinconnectet. Dieses Entry-Node sieht immer, und dem sagst du, was der nächste Server sein soll, der auch zum Tor-Netzwerk gehört. Und diese Daten, wer der nächste ist, das weiß der Entry-Node. Also das sagst du dem, wo du hin willst, aber da sind noch mehr Daten drin, die noch verschlüsselt sind und der nächste nicht entschlüsseln kann. Der erste nicht entschlüsseln kann, die aber der nächste entschlüsseln kann. Und der steht dann drin, wer der dritte ist, in dem Netzwerk. Und der wiederum kann dann die Daten für sich entschlüsseln und im Zweifel ist, dann kommt auch schon das Exit-Node und der weiß, wo es hingehen soll. Also der erste Server weiß nicht, wo du am Ende hin willst. Der zweite weiß auch noch nicht, wo du am Ende hin willst. Nur der dritte weiß, wo du hin willst. Aber der weiß nicht, wer der erste war.
Warte mal, ist das sozusagen so eine Art Schatzkiste?
Das ist eher Onion-Rooting, das heißt es sind Zwiebelschalen, so kann man sich das vorstellen.
Ich kann mir schon vorstellen, ich schicke eine Kiste los, zu einem Punkt. Der hat einen Schlüssel, der diese Kiste aufließen kann. Da ist eine weitere Kiste drin, die kann der aber nicht aufmachen. Aber er weiß, wo die Kiste hin soll. Bis am Ende sozusagen die Kiste, wo die eigentliche Nachricht drin ist.
Und die Idee ist, dass verschiedene Leute diese Infrastruktur betreiben. Interessanterweise gibt es natürlich sehr viele interessierte staatliche Stellen, die ein Interesse daran haben, möglichst viele von diesen Nodes zu betreiben, weil die natürlich auch versuchen möchten, da irgendwas draus zu gewinnen. Beziehungsweise es gibt auch Staaten, die das tatsächlich fördern wollen. Also die USA ist explizit auch dazu angetreten, dass das Tor-Netzwerk eben für Meinungsfreiheit. Und da kommen wir schon fast zum politischen Teil.
Weil ich wollte gerade sagen, ich wollte eigentlich nur wissen, was das ist, das Darknet. Das Darknet ist ein Ort, wo ich online kommunizieren kann, ohne dass der andere weiß, wo ich herkomme und wer ich bin.
Genau.
Also da weiß wirklich niemand, dass ich ein Hund bin.
Oder eine Katze oder eine Waschmaschine. Im Idealfall.
Ja, okay, aber so ist es gedacht. Das heißt, und jetzt ist die Annahme, weil sich da ein Mensch eine Waffe besorgt hat über dieses Darknet, da sind nur Verbrecher, deswegen muss das aufgemacht werden.
Was ist davon zu halten? Also das Darknet, genau da kommen wir jetzt in die politische Einordnung, ist im Wesentlichen auch dazu gedacht und auch dafür überhaupt gegründet worden, damit Meinungsaustausch so stattfinden kann, dass er nicht sensibel ist. Wir haben in der Vergangenheit sehr viele Versuche registriert von Staaten, die möchten, dass Verschlüsselung, die jetzt ja nach Snowden immer mehr auch eingefordert wird und implementiert wird, eben ein bisschen durchlässiger wird, weil ein Staat möchte natürlich prinzipiell erstmal wissen, was so passiert. Und da gibt es natürlich genug Regime auf dieser Welt, die das auch benutzen, um Dissidenten zu verfolgen und denen das Leben zur Hölle zu machen, um nicht zu sagen, ihnen nach dem Leben zu trachten. Und solche Leute können halt dank Tor sich untereinander oder halt mit Leuten in anderen Ländern sich austauschen, ohne akuter Lebensgefahr zu sehen.
Ja, aber Entschuldige, wir sind doch hier in Deutschland, würde dann sozusagen die verehrte Straffolgerin sagen. Und hier kann ja jeder seine freie Meinung sagen. Und wir haben jetzt diesen Fall, da werden Waffen verkauft.
Also müssen wir das hier verbieten. Die interessante Frage ist, wie du das tun, also wie würdest du dir ein Verbot vorstellen?
Ich weiß nicht, das geht doch bestimmt irgendwie technisch. Dafür haben wir doch Fachleute vom Bundesamt für Informationssicherheit oder so. Oder von CITES, der neuen Entschlüsselungsbehörde.
Du könntest da sicherlich vieles probieren. Aber es ist einfach nicht zielführend. Weil diese Notes tauchen halt schneller auf, als du sie sperren oder sonst irgendetwas.
Na ja, gut, aber es ist ja nur Fakt, dass da auch kriminelle Sachen bestehen. Was soll denn da passieren?
Das ist vollkommen richtig. Es ist aber nicht so, dass die Behörden da vollkommen schutzlos wären. Es ist schwierig. Allerdings gibt es genug oder es gibt zumindest auch Fahndungs- und Ermittlungserfolge. Gerade in diesem Waffenhändlerbereich gab es jetzt eine Verurteilung zu fünfeinhalb Jahren Haft gegen einen Waffenhändler, der im Darknet Waffen vertrieben hat oder vertrieben haben soll nach Ansicht des Gerichtes. Es scheint offensichtlich möglich zu sein, was daran liegt, dass diese Kommunikation auch immer mal wieder löchig ist. Man muss ja irgendwann auch Informationen austauschen, wie diese Waffen wandern sollen. Darüber kann man auch wieder ganz gut Ermittlungsansätze fahren. Man kommt dann dazu, dass zum Beispiel, wenn du einen Browser verwendest, dieser Browser hat ganz spezielle Charakteristiken, den nur ein PC hat auf dieser Welt. Zum Beispiel die Kombination aus Schriftarten, die du auf deinem Rechner installiert hast und Audio-Devices usw. Darüber kann man tatsächlich auch herausfinden, wer wer ist.
Dann würde ich wieder fragen, dann hilft das doch eigentlich gar nichts, weil darüber kann ich auch die Dissidenten, die wir...
Das ist vollkommen richtig. Aber ich glaube tatsächlich im Zusammenhang mit diesen Waffen ist wichtig, die Waffe muss ja irgendwie auch noch die Grenze überqueren.
Und da erwischt man die Leute.
Das heißt, das Darknet an sich ist kein gefährlicher Ort?
Das Darknet ist auf jeden Fall viel zu wichtig, um es quasi nur auf solche Sachen zu reduzieren.
Gibt es auch einen anderen Namen für?
Also tatsächlich ist dieser Begriff Darknet irgendwann mal in den Medien aufgetaucht. Und ich muss sagen, ich hab persönlich ganz lange einfach das Ganze unter dem Namen Thor, unter dem es eigentlich auch landläufig geht. Thor ist zwar nur ein Beispiel, aber es ist de facto so das, was die Leute gerne nehmen. Der Darknet Standard. Genau.
Okay, gut. Eine kurze Erklärung, was eigentlich ein Darknet ist. Und wir fangen dann gleich an mit dem richtigen Thema. Vorher noch eine kurze Musik von Cala Soleil und Swamp. Ich bin der Swamp von ColorSolid hier im Chaosradio auf fritz.de, wo wir heute über, naja, im weitesten Sinne Digitales Geld reden wollen und dazu noch mal herzlich willkommen Dennis, Dirk und Christian.
Hallo noch mal.
Hallo.
Sehr schön. Und wir wollen halt also wirklich, also Digitales Geld ist wirklich das Oberthema und es geht über verschiedene Arten und Weisen, wie Geld von einem Punkt zum anderen kommt. Und wir wollen da sozusagen sehr, also es wird heute noch esoterisch heute Abend, wie sich das fürs Chaosradio gehört, verspreche ich. Aber wir fangen erstmal ganz bodenständig an und vielleicht habt ihr das erlebt, wenn ihr irgendwie in einem Laden wartet und was gekauft habt. Da gibt es eine neue Art von, wie man mit Kredit oder EC-Karte bezahlen kann. Das sind halt nicht diese normalen Terminals, wo man, wo man, wo die halt reingesteckt wird, da gibt man seinen PIN an, da kommt ein Zettel raus, den man unterschreiben muss, sondern das ist eine kleine, meist, ja nicht, ja doch quadratisch, also von der Fläche zumindest box, da wird die Karte reingesteckt und dann hängt dann irgendwie so ein Pad oder einen Smartphone dran. Dirk, was genau ist das und worin unterscheidet es sich von einem herkömmlichen Plastikartenterminal?
Na also der Unterschied ist eigentlich gar nicht so groß. Im Grunde hat man dieses normale Terminal, was alle kennen oder was man von früher schon kennt, in zwei Geräte aufgespalten und das eine ist ein Smartphone oder ein iPad oder ein Tablet und das andere Gerät ist halt nur noch der Kartenleser, der auch noch einen Pin-Entry haben sollte zumindest und ein kleines Display hat, wo nur der Betrag angezeigt wird und die Aufforderung, also die üblichen Aufforderungen bitte jetzt Karte einstecken, jetzt Pin eingeben, natürlich sollte man als Nutzer dann auch noch den Betrag überprüfen, weil der auf dem Smartphone eingegebene Betrag kann sich durchaus unterscheiden zu dem, der auf dem Pin-Pad dann erscheint. Also der auf dem Pin-Pad ist der entscheidende Betrag. Und ja, dann gibt man die Pin ein und dann kommt halt die Nachrichtkarte entfernen und dann ist es erledigt. Also im Grunde genauso wie vorher, wie bei den alten Kartenterminals. Aber dadurch, dass jetzt sozusagen das aufgeteilt wurde in Mobiltelefon oder mobiles Device und Kartenterminal, dadurch können diese Kartenterminals billiger sein, weil ja der Merchant, also der Händler, auch noch das Mobiltelefon eh schon haben muss. Und das macht die Internetverbindung und das redet auch mit dem Backend, wobei allerdings das Telefon als unsicher angesehen wird von den Herstellern dieser Geräte. Und es ist ja auch unsicher.
Eine Frage vorher noch, das ist aber nicht so, dass die alten Kartenlesegeräten gegen die neuen aufgetauscht werden, sondern wenn ich es richtig mitbekommen habe, ist diese neue Art Karten abzurechnen, das sind auch immer eigene Startups quasi.
Weiß ich gar nicht, ob das jetzt immer noch so ist, aber zumindest der erste Firma, die das gemacht hat, war Square in den USA, aber die wollten halt auch nur in den USA bleiben und sind nicht nach Europa gekommen und deshalb haben sich in Europa diverse Firmen gegründet, die genau dieses Konzept nachgemacht haben.
Aber das sind schon neue Firmen und nicht die alten marktbeherrschenden Anbieter, die die neuen, diese normalen Abrichtungsgeräte so fügen.
Ja, das sind neue Firmen und auch nicht die Firmen, die vorher die Terminals hergestellt haben. Also es gibt auch ein paar kleine Firmen, die diese Terminals herstellen und die neuen Firmen sind soweit ich weiß alles ganz neue Firmen, die sozusagen bei Null angefangen haben und die am Anfang glaube ich auch gar keine eigene Banklizenz brauchten, sondern ohne anfangen konnten und ja.
Und das ist aber vom Geldfluss her ist es dasselbe sozusagen. Also da wird diese Karte wird sozusagen technisch ausgelesen und dann fließt das Geld sozusagen von dem einen Girokonto auf das andere Konto. Oder gibt es dann noch weitere Schritte?
Nee, technisch gesehen passiert da das gleiche, nur eben diese Aufteilung zwischen Terminal und Mobiltelefon und dann Backend. Ja, die Karten sind auch die gleiche. Also die Anbieter, die da angetreten sind, die sind mit dem Ziel angetreten billiger zu sein und niedrigere Mindestbeträge zu erlauben. Also bei diesen großen Terminals, bei den alten Terminals, hat der Händler halt immer eine Grundgebühr, so um die 200 Euro, die er im Monat zahlen muss. Und das machen dann halt nur Händler, die auch wissen, dass viele Leute bei ihnen mit Karte zahlen würden. Und diese neuen Anbieter, die haben in der Regel keine Grundgebühr. Man muss halt einmal dieses Terminal kaufen. Und das kostet so um die 60, 70 Euro. Und dann kann man da mit Kartenzahlungen entgegennehmen und muss dann immer den Prozentbetrag, also bei EC-Karten 1% in der Regel und bei Kreditkarten 2-3% vom Umsatz. Und der Mindestbetrag ist dann 1 Euro, das heißt, man kann sein Eis quasi mit Kreditkarte kaufen. Das ist sozusagen der Unterschied. Vorher hast du halt 10 Euro Mindestumsatz gehabt. Ja, lustigerweise, es gibt da so ein System, was irgendwie total skurril ist. Also wenn es nicht mit Chip und Pin ist, sondern mit Chip und Signature, dann unterschreibt man auf dem Display des Telefons. Also man wischt dann seine Unterschrift aufs Telefon. Klingt erstmal total bescheuert, wird aber anscheinend akzeptiert.
Also, weil jetzt wollte ich gerade fragen, du hast es auch schon gesagt, also denn Telefon ist ja ein Computer und das ist ja wiederum ein System, was tendenzell vierenverseucht ist. Also zumindest sein kann. Also bietet auf jeden Fall eine größere anadrige Fläche als diese normalen Abrechnungsgeräte, die ja auch gehackt werden können, wie man sozusagen auf jedem Chaos-Kongress immer wieder sieht. Aber wie ist denn das? Du hast schon gesagt, das System sieht das Telefon irgendwie als unsicher an, aber wie kann das denn miteinander kommunizieren?
Ja, also die Sicherheit steckt bei diesem Verfahren sozusagen in dem Terminal. Das ist mit entsprechender Hardware abgesichert und da stecken sozusagen die geheimen Schlüssel drin, mit denen dann die Sachen verschlüsselt werden, die über das Mobiltelefon dann verschickt werden. Das heißt, das Mobiltelefon kann nicht dekodieren, was in den Paketen drin steht, die da versendet werden. Und deshalb ist es auch so wichtig, dass man den Betrag, den Zahlbetrag am Terminal überprüft. Weil was man im Telefon eingibt, kann durchaus was anderes sein, was das Telefon dann ans Backend schickt.
Also quasi das Telefon ist für die eigentliche Überweisung nur so eine Art Modem. Das kann aber inhaltlich nichts beeinflussen.
Und ein Eingabeterminal für den Preis.
Und eventuell die Unterschrift.
Das wundert mich.
Aber das wundert mich tatsächlich gerade, weil die Unterschrift ist sozusagen was ganz wichtiges.
Das ist, damit sie sich den Drucker ersparen können.
Anscheinend ist die Unterschrift nicht so wichtig. Also kann man ja nicht anders sagen, weil mit dem Finger auf dem Display, da unterschreibst du doch nicht, wie auf dem Zettel mit dem Kugelschreiber.
Es gibt ja eh gesagt einen Unterschied zwischen Pin-Eingabe und Unterschrifteneingabe. Kannst du das noch kurz erklären?
Ja, bei der Pin-Eingabe ist es so, dass der Händler sich sicher sein kann, dass er das Geld kriegt. Und bei der Unterschrift ist es halt nicht unbedingt sicher. Also wenn da ein Dispute stattfindet, wenn der Käufer hinterher sagt, ne, habe ich nicht da gekauft, will mein Geld wieder haben, dann ist es bei der Unterschrift für den Händler schwerer, an sein Geld zu kommen, während es bei der Pin abgesichert ist. Und Pin ist halt teurer.
Für den Händler, also muss er extra bezahlen.
Wobei tatsächlich bei diesen Anbietern ist es alles der gleiche Preis. Aber im Supermarkt ist es für den Supermarkt teurer, Pin zu verwenden als Unterschrift.
Aber jetzt noch mal zusammenfassend, ist doch eigentlich die ganze Geschichte keine technische Neuerung, sondern ist doch nur, dass da ein neuer Anbieter kommt und irgendwie seine eigenen Geräte bei den Händlern irgendwie aufstellen will, damit er ein bisschen was verdient. Also für die Kunden, für uns ist sozusagen nichts Neues. Für den Händler, der spart dann ein paar Euro und das ist einfach mehr Konkurrenz beim Cash Terminal Markt, oder?
Ja, das ist keine Revolution.
Die Frage, die wir gerade stellen, ist, sind diese Geräte wirklich sozusagen so viel billiger oder ist das nur so eine Art Vorwand, um sagen zu können, wir haben jetzt sozusagen ein neues Gerät, ihr nutzt euer Smartphone, deswegen können wir es billiger anbieten, aber im Prinzip ist es eigentlich nur ein Preiskampf.
Das kann ich nicht beurteilen.
Also für mich hört sich das nach Preiskampf an.
Was man ja auch machen kann, ist, auf dem Tablet kann man dann noch irgendwelche zusätzliche Software anbieten, die dann zusätzlich zur Zahlung noch irgendwie Buchhaltung macht oder was auch immer. Also ich weiß nicht, ob die das machen, aber...
Ja, das wird gemacht. Also man kann seinen Warenkorb da verwalten und dann muss man nicht den Preis eingeben, sondern kann halt einfach das Produkt antippen auf dem Telefon und dann wird genau dieses Produkt in die Rechnung getan. Es wird auch beim Rechnungsdrucken geholfen. Es gibt ja so ein Zahlungsbackend, wo dann der Händler hinterher sich irgendwie im Web angucken kann, was er so eingenommen hat.
Da gibt es schon extra Services, die noch oben drauf kommen. Würdet ihr ihm jetzt genauso oder anders vertrauen als einem normal herkömmlichen Plastikkartenterminal?
Naja, wenn man es genau nimmt, kann man diesem Terminal nicht ansehen, ob es manipuliert wurde oder nicht.
Kann ich dem Großen aber auch nicht.
Aber umso mehr Terminals da umstehen, umso unsicher wird es. Weil irgendwann kennt man ja die Standard-Terminals. Jetzt kommen da wieder ganz viele neue und jeder macht sein eigenes. Jeder hat ein anderes Smartphone dran kleben. Man blickt gar nicht mehr durch und weiß dann nicht, bei welchem jetzt manipuliert wurde oder bei welchem nicht. Wobei, das stimmt schon, das kann man sowieso nicht sehen, weil die brechen nachts ein, bauen das Ding um. Das siehst du von außen nicht.
Würdest du lieber Babel zahlen, wenn du siehst, dass die diesen neuen Service, diesen neuen Terminal benutzen?
Ich sag ja, aus Kundensicht ist das egal. Ob ich meine EC-Karte in ein Ding schiebe oder in das andere ist mir eigentlich wurscht.
Also ich würde das auch eher bei der Liability so sehen. Dann würde ich eher eine Kreditkarte benutzen, weil da weiß ich, dass das mit dem Chargeback gut funktioniert.
Chargeback bitte was?
Na also wenn ich einen Dispute mache und sage, ich hab das nicht autorisiert, dann hab ich bisher die gute Erfahrung gemacht, dass ich immer mein Geld zurückbekommen habe. Das wär vielleicht auch eine Frage an die Hörer, die mal betrogen wurden und wie das bei ihnen gelaufen ist.
Interessanter Punkt in der Tat, also wenn ihr da draußen steht und sagt, ich habe mal ein Problem mit einer Plastekarte gehabt, weil irgendwie Dinge abgebucht wurden oder meine Karte kopiert, wo ich nicht gemerkt habe, könnt ihr gerne anrufen unter 0331 70 97 122. Uns würde interessieren, wie einfach das war mit der entsprechenden Bank oder anderen Firma zu reden und da das Geld wiederzubekommen. So, dann haben wir jetzt Plastegeld, was der erste Schritt weg von der Münze gemacht, und werden dann gleich mal reden über, wie soll man sagen, Online-Konten eigentlich, mehr oder weniger. Es gibt einen neuen Anbieter, der heißt Number26, und der war zumindest auf Twitter in den News, wo das immer gesagt wurde, hier so ein neuer Online-Konto-Anbieter. Und ich hatte auch das Gefühl, es gibt mehr, es gibt sozusagen so ein neues Fintech-Startup, heißt das. Also was das genau ist, was man mit so einem Konto machen kann, das klären wir gleich. Vorher machen wir aber die Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr, und dann geht es hier weiter im Chaosradio.
Seit letztem Jahr hat Berlin einen riesigen neuen Stern am Festivalhimmel mit so einem einprägsamen Namen.
Fritz präsentiert das Lollapalooza-Festival.
In diesem Jahr mit Major Lazer, Kings of Leon, Milky Chance, Radiohead und Philipp Porzell. Mit Dimitri Vegas und Mike, Max Herre und Paul Kalkbrenner. Und das sind längst noch nicht alle. Am 10. und 11. September. Im, am und rund um den Treptower Park. Lollapalooza Berlin präsentiert von Fritz.
Bundeskanzlerin Merkel ist davon überzeugt, dass Deutschland die Herausforderungen durch die Flüchtlingskrise meistern wird. Das sagte sie heute auf einer Pressekonferenz. Merkel will mit einem neuen Punkteplan für mehr Sicherheit in Deutschland sorgen. Unter anderem sollen Vorbereitungen getroffen werden, dass die Bundeswehr bei großen Terroranschlägen auch im Inland eingesetzt werden kann, sagte Merkel. Außerdem sollen demnach die Hürden für die Abschiebung von Asylbewerbern gesenkt werden. Die französischen Behörden haben Gedenkmärsche für die Opfer der jüngsten Anschläge aus Sicherheitsgründen verboten. Ein für Sonntag geplanter Marsch in Nizza wurde wegen der starken Belastung der Polizei nicht genehmigt. Um die Sicherheitslage in Frankreich zu verbessern, will Frankreichs Präsident Hollande so schnell wie möglich eine Nationalgarde bilden lassen. Die soll aus Reservisten bestehen und die regulären Sicherheitskräfte entlasten. Ein jugendlicher Drogendealer muss nach der Attacke gegen zwei Polizisten ins Gefängnis. Der 17-Jährige hatte gestern Abend in Berlin-Kreuzberg zwei Zivilfahnder zum Teil schwer verletzt. Sie hatten ihn beobachtet, als er am Spreewaldplatz nahe dem Görlitzer Park Drogen verkaufte. Als sich die Fahnder zu erkennen gaben, hatte der Jugendliche direkt auf sie eingeschlagen. Der Angriff des Dealers war so heftig, dass einer Kommissarin das Jochbein gebrochen wurde und sie eine Verletzung in der Augenhöhle erlitt. Die schwer verletzte Polizistin muss operiert werden. Ihr Kollege musste ambulant behandelt werden. Fußball-Bundesligist Hertha BSC ist nach 6, 5 Jahren zurück auf der europäischen Fußballbühne. Die Berliner gewannen das Hinspiel in der 3. Runde der Europa League Qualifikation gegen das dänische Team Brøndby IF mit 1 zu 0. Das siegt Toros Chos Ibisevic in der 28. Minute. Das Rückspiel findet am 4. August in Kopenhagen statt. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin-Pankow sind 19°C in Rheinikendorf 22°C, Frankfurt an der Oder und Neuglobso haben 19°C, Lindenberg und Potsdam 21°C. In der Nacht ziehen von Südwesten her einzelne Schauer und Gewitter ran, teilweise auch mit kräftigem Starkregen. Es kühlt sich ab auf bis zu 16°C. Morgens lassen die Schauer dann nach. Es lockert auf und wird recht freundlich mit Sonne und Wolken im Wechsel. Bei maximal 26°C erst am Abend kann es dann wieder neue Schauer geben. Im Stadtverkehr Berlin in Charlottenburg ist die Kahnstraße zwischen Joachimsthaler Straße und Fasanenstraße wegen eines Kraneinsatzes voll gesperrt bis um 3 Uhr morgens früh. In Friedrichshain an der Ostbahn gibt es in Höhe am Wrietzen einen Kraneinsatz und eine Nachtbaustelle. Dort ebenfalls eine Sperrung bis um 5 Uhr früh. In Prenzlauer Berg kann es sich nach dem Härterspiel rund um den Friedrich-Ludwig-Jahren-Sportpark stauen. Es gibt immer noch Sperrungen wegen der Überschwemmungen. In Gesundbrunn ist der Gleimtunnel betroffen. In Schöneberg die Hohenstaufenstraße zwischen Martin Luther und Münchener Straße. In Brandenburg auf der A12 Berlin Richtung Frankfurt-Oder. Zwischen Fürstenwalde Ost und Briesen steht ein kaputter Laster auf der rechten Spur. Auf der A12 Berlin Richtung Frankfurt-Oder zwischen Mühlrose und Frankfurt-Oder West gibt's Stau. Auf der A13 Berlin Richtung Dresden zwischen Schönefelder Kreuz und Rago gibt's Fahrradfahrer auf der Straße. Vorsicht auch auf der A13 Dresden Richtung Berlin. In Höhe Schönefelder Kreuz gibt's Gefahr durch Fahrradfahrer auf der Straße. Dort bitte aufpassen. Auf der A24 Berlin Richtung Hamburg zwischen Dreieck Witzstockdosse und Pritzweg sind Leute auf der Standspur. Auf der A24 Hamburg Richtung Berlin zwischen Parchim und Dreieck Haveland ist ein Schwertransporter unterwegs und darf nicht überholt werden. Auf der A24 Hamburg Richtung Berlin zwischen Pritzweg und Dreieck Witzstockdosse sind ebenfalls Leute auf der Straße. Ansonsten, Davos geht, gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des Airbaby.
Und wenn ihr Fritz für die Hosentasche wollt, mit Livestream, Studio Message, Podcasts und jede Menge mehr, dann holt euch doch die Fritz App kostenlos und werbefrei in eurem App oder Play Store.
Tschüss.
Und der Blohmun ist heute das Chaos Radio hier auf Fritz, wo der Chaos Computer Club da ist und zwar in Gestalt der Menschen Dennis, Dirk und Christian. Hallo und guten Abend nochmal. Hallo. Und wir reden heute über digitales Geld, also genau genommen digitalen Währungstransfer. Also wie kommt Geld von einem zum anderen? Wir haben gerade schon darüber geredet, dass Plastikarten so ein neues System haben, mit dem man sie auslesen kann in einem Laden, was gar nicht so ein großer Unterschied ist, wo es nur für die Händler ein bisschen billiger wird, wo man kleinere Beträge bezahlen kann. Das ist genauso unsicher wie vorher, also nichts Großes. Und dann gibt es Neues sozusagen, oder es gibt eigentlich immer wieder mal so Anbieter, die sagen, ja wir sind jetzt das neue Online-Konto und das unterscheidet sich für mich zumindest gar nicht so sehr von einem Herklempe-Girokonto, nur dass es so Komfortfunktion hat, dass man da wirklich alles im Webbrowser machen kann, das ein bisschen besser funktioniert als die Webseite einer alten Bank. Aber es ist doch ein bisschen was anderes. Der erste Anbieter, der mir begegnet ist, ist Fedor gewesen. Und jetzt hat er öfter mal, zumindest in meiner Timeline auf Twitter, in Number 26 immer wieder vorgekommen. Manche Leute fanden das irgendwie toll, manche Leute haben darüber geschimpft, und ich weiß doch gar nicht so richtig, was das ist. Und deswegen könnt ihr mir das vielleicht erklären. Number 26, was ist das eigentlich? Was machen die?
Was soll das?
Das guckt mich gerade ganz erschreckt an.
Also ich bin Kunde tatsächlich. Ich habe einen Zweitkonto sozusagen da. Und bei mir waren das ganz pragmatische Gründe. Und dann habe ich halt so ein paar nette Features gefunden. Also ganz pragmatisch in dem Sinne, dass man da halt jeden Bankautomaten benutzen kann in der Stadt und nicht nur die von der Bank, bei der man ist. Ohne Gebühren, genau. Das gibt es auch bei anderen Banken, aber da muss man immer eine Mindesteinlage haben. Und da hätte ich dann so zahlend alles umstellen müssen. Und so habe ich einfach mir dieses Konto geklickt und verifiziert. Und mich authentif, nein, mich, wie sagt man, bekannt gemacht, dem Anbieter. Und wofür es halt auch noch praktisch ist, im europäischen Ausland Geld abzuheben, Bargeld abzuheben, das kostet ja sonst auch immer Gebühren. Und dann was auch noch ganz nett ist, wenn man Geld abhebt, dann kriegt man halt gleich, also man hat eine App dazu auf dem Mobiltelefon, iPhone und Android. Und man kriegt halt, bevor das Geld noch schon rauskommt, hat man schon die Nachricht bekommen, wie viel man abgehoben hat und dass es funktioniert hat. Und man kann die Karten auch selektiv sperren zum Beispiel. Also wenn man nicht weiß, dass man demnächst nichts im Internet kauft, dann schaltet man die Internetbezahlfunktion für die Kreditkarte einfach in der App kurzfristig ab. Also man muss nicht gleich die ganze Karte sperren. Also die haben sich schon einiges an Komfort da einfallen lassen. Das kommt natürlich auch alles zu einem Preis. Also der Preis ist nicht, dass man da Gebühren bezahlt, sondern da man keine Gebühren bezahlt, also ich kann da zwar nur spekulieren, aber ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass es genauso ist, dass halt mit den Daten, die da anfallen, von einem das Geschäft gemacht wird. Und dessen sollte man sich bewusst sein, wenn man so einen Konto eröffnet. Na ich weiß nicht, ob es so schlimm ist. Ich meine, also ich benutze es hauptsächlich, um an Bargeld zu kommen. Ich überweise da monatlich ein bisschen Geld hin auf das Konto und dann kann ich mir halt, wenn mal kein Automat in der Nähe ist, was abheben.
Aber was ist da zwischen sozusagen dieser Einrichtung und einer normalen Bank? Was machen die denn anders? Oder ist es einfach nur sozusagen eine besonders online-affine Bank?
Das würde ich so sagen, ja. Und die App ist auch gut zu bedienen. Und was glaube ich auch einfach ist, ich habe viele Kollegen, die nicht aus Deutschland kommen, sondern die aus dem europäischen Ausland kommen und die kriegen halt sehr leicht bei Number26 ein Konto. Für die ist es, also ich glaube in meinem Berliner Office haben alle Nicht-Deutschen ein Number26-Konto einfach, weil es so einfach zu kriegen ist.
Also der Prozess ein Konto zu öffnen, da ist auch irgendwie relativ schick, sage ich mal. Weil das geht komplett übers Handy. Man muss nicht in irgendeine Bank gehen und irgendwie Papier abgeben. Also es ist alles übers Handy und es ist alles irgendwie schön einfach zu kriegen.
Ich könnte mir da auch unter falschen Namen ein Konto machen etwa.
Kannst ja mal versuchen. Ich meine, die machen so eine Videokonferenz mit dir. Also die rufen dich auf dem Telefon mit Video an und dann musst du deinen Personalausweis, also deine ID-Card so in die Kamera halten, während sie mit dir sprechen und dann gucken sie so nach den Merkmalen. Ach, hast du auch gemacht für Bitcoin-Exchanges.
Ja, ne, gemacht habe ich es noch nicht, aber ich kenne einen Bitcoin-Bude, wo man das machen muss, wenn man größere Transaktionen machen möchte.
Es wird anscheinend als sicher angesehen, über eine Videokonferenz einen Ausweis zu zeigen.
Ähm, also mal davon abgesehen. Ich habe davon gelesen, dass es auch Ärger gibt, weil Überweisungen irgendwie nicht so schnell gehen und weil auch irgendwie Leute rausgeworfen wurden.
Ja, genau, vor kurzem gab es den Ärger, weil in Deutschland ist es halt sehr teuer für so einen Anbieter, tatsächlich an jedem Automaten das Abheben zu erlauben. Und das haben sie irgendwie anscheinend nicht mit einberechnet, dass Leute das dann mehrmals im Monat machen oder alle zwei bis drei Tage.
Warte mal, sie bieten einen Service an und rechnen damit, dass Leute ihn nicht nutzen?
Ja. So wie mit den Internet-Leitungen, wenn du deine DSL-Leitung zu doll nutzt, dann wird man ja auch gerne mal gekündigt, wenn man die überstrapaziert.
Also da sind wohl 500 Leute gekündigt worden und was jetzt dabei rausgekommen ist, dass sie gesagt haben, wer mehr als dreimal im Monat abhebt und das nicht als Eingangskonto für sein Gehalt benutzt, wie auch immer sie das feststellen wollen, also größere Summen monatlich Eingänge hat, der zahlt dann beim vierten Abheben dann 2 Euro pro Abhebung. Also das ist jetzt die Änderung.
Das ist aber auch totaler Quatsch.
Na ja, so ist jetzt, damit wollen sie verhindern, dass Leute zu oft...
Du hast ja gerade gesagt, für dich war das Hauptkriterium, Bargeld zu besorgen.
Ja gut, das kann ich jetzt noch 2-3 Mal im Monat machen.
Und was ist jetzt sonst noch so toll?
Genau, ich hatte gehofft, dass sie mir das erklären kann.
Das ist einfach nur das, was die anderen Banken nicht machen. Alle anderen Banken könnten das genauso gut machen, aber die machen es halt.
Und ist das auch eine Bank?
Sie haben inzwischen auch eine eigene Banklizenz. Sie waren lange bei Wirecard angehängt.
Was heißt das?
Dass sie eine eigene Banklizenz haben.
Was heißt das, bei Wirecard angehängt zu sein?
Na, da gab es dann glaube ich auch nur, es gibt eh nur Maestro und Mastercard. Also Wirecard ist halt so ein Anbieter für Kreditkarten.
Virtuelle Kreditkarten.
Ja, virtuelle Kreditkarten, genau. Du kannst auch eine richtige Karte zugeschickt kriegen. Also auch bei Wirecard. Ja, und deren Banklizenz haben sie mitgenutzt. Und jetzt haben sie ihre eigene. Auch keine große Sache.
Ich bin jetzt ein bisschen verwirrt, weil alles, was immer so als so, das ist was völlig Neues kommuniziert wird, ist eigentlich sozusagen das, was alle schon immer gemacht haben, nur weil sich mal jemand hingesetzt hat, hat es modernisiert. Kann man das so sagen?
Ja, es ist keine Revolution. Alle anderen Banken könnten das auch schon lange gemacht haben.
Dann würde ich zum Schluss, was dann das letzte Thema ist, was man vielleicht schon mal gehört hat, wenn man sich nicht tiefer mit der Materie beschäftigt, zu virtuellem Geld kommen, kann man das so sagen? Also es gibt mittlerweile so ein paar Anbieter, wie also Kringle zum Beispiel oder Paypal macht das auch, oder wie es Grill hieß das, wo man sich bei einem Online-Dienst anmeldet und da Geld einzahlt. Und dann kann man das sozusagen zwischen anderen Leuten auch angemeldet sind hin und her schieben.
Aber es ist ja immer noch kein virtuelles Geld.
Sondern?
Na, es ist schon echtes Geld, was die auch hin und her schieben.
Ja, okay, diese Diskussion wollte ich jetzt nicht anfangen, bitte, bitte, bitte.
Aber eigentlich ist Paypal jetzt auch nichts anderes als eine modernere Bank, würde ich fast behaupten.
Also quasi, das ist auch nur, wenn ich schiebe mein Geld zu denen und dann haben die quasi ein großes Bankkonto irgendwo und verwalten aber intern, wem was gehört.
Du hast halt nur keine Kontonummer, sondern du hast dann da deine E-Mail-Adresse abbenutzt, die irgendwie. Und dann kann man so das Geld da von Person A zu Person B schieben. Aber das war's eigentlich auch schon. Also da ist jetzt nichts. Die haben ja keine eigene Währung, sondern sie nutzt. Das ist so ein Zusatzangebot. Aber sonst ist da doch nichts Spezielles dran eigentlich.
Naja, nichts Spezielles im Sinne schon. Also bei der Bank sozusagen, da streiten die Finanznerds und sagen auch wieder, das stimmt alles gar nicht. Das Geld ist nicht sicher. Aber bei der Bank ist ja mein Geld relativ sicher. Ich weiß nicht, ob PayPal mittlerweile auch eine Banklizenz hat, aber es gibt ja mehrere solche Online-Dienste. Die haben ja dann mein Geld und kann mir irgendjemand garantieren, dass ich da wieder rauskriege?
Also in Deutschland müssen sie zumindest eine Banklizenz haben, wenn sie für dich Geld aufheben. Also wenn sie es nicht sofort weiterleiten, sondern es auch nur eine Sekunde aufheben, dann brauchen sie in Deutschland eine Banklizenz.
Dann musst du sozusagen den Einlageschutz da gewährleisten. Du musst ja so und so viel Prozent von deinen Einnahmen hinterlegen. Das war relativ wenig Prozent, aber wenn alle abheben, haben die Banken und auch PayPal ein Problem. Aber du musst halt so eine gewisse Summe hinterlegen.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass PayPal gar kein Problem hat, weil die gar nichts verleihen und auch nicht Kredite rausgeben, sondern die operieren nur mit dem, was sie auch reinkriegen. Insofern hätten die dann 100 Prozent Einlage.
Zumindest sehe ich an PayPal im Vergleich zu Banken jetzt nicht so viel Spezielles. Außer, dass die online besser auftreten und schon zielgerichtet da auf die Kunden zu gehen. Aber am Ende ist noch nichts mit brutteller Währung. Es gibt ja keine PayPal-Coins, dann wäre es interessant. Die gibt es aber nicht, sie erhantieren in Euros und in Dollars.
Okay, es gibt keine PayPal-Coins. Na gut, dann kommen wir aber jetzt zu dem Punkt, wo wir es hinwechseln, weil es gibt ja Bitcoins. Man muss dazusagen, wir haben schon mal eine Sendung zu Bitcoins gemacht. Das heißt, wenn euch das Thema in aller Tiefe interessiert, dann könnt ihr die hören. Ich hab jetzt eine Nummer vergessen.
169.
169, genau, Chaosradio 169 auf chaosradio.ccc.de. Wir erklären es heute noch mal kurz sozusagen, aber haben natürlich nicht die ganze 2 Stunden Zeit. Bitcoin ist jetzt eine virtuelle Währung eigentlich? Warum? Was ist denn Bitcoin?
Also noch mal ganz kurz gefragt. Das ist schwierig, das muss man so weit ausholen, weil irgendwie das Gold ist ja auch nicht mehr wirklich hinterlegt. So gesehen sind die Euros ja auch schon irgendwie der Kurs, weiß nicht, wie man das erklären soll. Aber Bitcoin ist halt eine eigene Währung schon mal. Also ist nicht irgendwie an den Euro gebunden oder an die Dollars oder sonst die. Es ist auch kein Gold dafür hinterlegt irgendwo, dass man sagen könnte, wenn alles zusammenbricht, so jetzt will ich aber für meine Bitcoins, weil die sind jetzt nichts mehr wert, will ich jetzt mein Gold wieder haben, was irgendwo im Tresor liegt. Das gibt es auch alles nicht. Deswegen ist das schon, würde ich sagen mal, virtuell, künstlich geschaffen, so könnte man das auch nennen. Und ja, die fragen überhaupt, ob es eine virtuelle Währung ist?
Ja, würde ich so sagen.
Und man kann sein Bitcoin-Konto auch nicht überziehen. Das ist glaube ich auch ein ganz wichtiger Aspekt.
Das heißt, Dispo gibt es nicht.
Okay, aber noch mal ganz kurz sagen, wie funktioniert denn Bitcoin? Also was genau passiert denn da?
Also der ein großer Unterschied im Gegensatz zu einer Bank ist, dass wenn die Bank mein Geld hat, dann hat sie mein Geld. Und wenn die Bank pleite ist, wie auch immer, was da so passiert hatten wir vor ein paar Jahren, dann ist das Geld weg. Bei Bitcoin kann man sein Geld selber bei sich zu Hause verwalten in seiner Bitcoin-Wallet, also in seinem Portemonnaie.
Das ist immer eine Software, ne?
Das ist eine Software, ja, weil die Bitcoins sind ja virtuell, also sind ja in Bits gespeichert, also Bitcoin. Und niemand kann mir die dann klauen, sondern ich verwalte meine Bitcoin selber. Und wenn ich jetzt hier, sagen wir, mit Dirk, wenn wir irgendwie ein Geschäft abschließen wollen, oder ich, sagen wir mal, schenk ihm einen Bitcoin zum Geburtstag, ich bin ja aber so nett, und dann kann ich das ohne Hilfe von anderen, mehr oder weniger, da gibt es also nicht ganz, aber kann ich das von mir zu ihm schieben und brauch da keine Bank für oder keinen sonst wen.
Ja, niemand kann das verhindern.
Und niemand kann das verhindern.
Ja, aber Entschuldige, wenn das so ist, dann mach ich jetzt hier so meine Bitcoin-Software auf. Also da sind ja 100.000 Bitcoins drin.
Ja, das ist korrekt. Und jetzt kommt wieder der nächste Unterschied. Bei einer Bank, wir gehen jetzt mal die Computer, lassen wir jetzt weg, aber bei einer Bank, wenn ich da irgendwie meine, früher bei einer 1000 D-Mark damals eingezahlt hab, dann saß da so ein Buch, der hat eingetragen, hier der Dennis 1000 D-Mark hat eingetragen, ja, das 1000 D-Mark, bin ich nach einem Monat wieder hin, hat er geguckt, alles klar, 1000 D-Mark sind noch da, kann ich mir jetzt wieder austeilen. Das heißt, die Buchführung fand in der Bank statt. Und wenn man bescheisen wollte, musste man sozusagen in die Bank einbrechen nachts oder so, und an der Buchführung musste man schummeln. Aber es ging nur innerhalb der Bank, die war geschützt, kennen wir ja Bankentresore und so weiter, kam man halt nicht so ran. Aber die Bank hätte theoretisch können, wenn sie wollte. So bei Bitcoins ist es aber so, da es ja keinen gibt, der es verhindern kann, der zwischen mir und zwischen dem Dirk unsere Überweisung verhindern kann, gibt es auch keine zentrale Stelle, die das irgendwie überwacht. Gleichzeitig aber damit das halt, damit auch ich und Dirk und überhaupt alle die Leute, die Bitcoin nutzen, nicht schummeln können, überwachen wir uns eigentlich alle gegenseitig. Das heißt, es ist ein riesengroßes Netzwerk und jeder sieht, was jeder macht. Das heißt, wenn ich halt dem Dirk was rüberschiebe, dann landet das im gesamten Bitcoin-Netzwerk und jeder weiß, dass ich das getan habe. Und dann weiß auch jeder, der Dennis, der hat diesen einen Bitcoin nicht mehr, sondern den hat jetzt der Dirk.
Also es wird sozusagen das Recht weitergegeben, das auszugeben. Es gibt auch nicht einfach so eine Ziffernfolge, die dann einem Bitcoin entspricht, sondern man gibt das Recht weiter, das auszugeben.
Okay, also im Prinzip in der Software sozusagen ist programmiert, dass...
Das ist verteilte Buchführung, könnte man das nennen.
Okay, also der Software ist programmiert, dass jeder, der diese Software benutzt, sozusagen die Dinge, die er hat, hin und her schieben kann. Und dass sich alle aufschreiben, wer was hin und her geschoben hat.
Genau, weil es ist wichtig, warum das nicht passieren darf, weil wenn ich meinen Bitcoins in den Dirk schiebe, könnte ich ja dann kurz danach sagen, naja, also diese virtuellen Bits, die hab ich ja, ich hab mir vorher eine Kopie gemacht, kennt man ja auf dem Rechner, man macht sich eine Kopie von seiner Datei und die Bitcoins sind ja auch nichts weiter als eine Datei. Kopiere ich mir die und schick dir den Bitcoin auch nochmal. Geile Idee. Und dann sieht aber das gesamte Bitcoin-Netzwerk, du hast die vorher schon an den Dirk geschoben, du darfst die nicht nochmal woanders hinschieben, das nennt man dann Double Spending und das sehen alle, dass es nicht erlaubt, das geht dann nicht mehr.
Okay, so.
Deswegen müssen das alle sehen, damit man nicht bescheißen kann.
Okay, habe ich jetzt verstanden. Wie viele Bitcoins gibt es?
Zurzeit glaube ich irgendwas zwischen 14 und 15 Millionen. Und wo kommen die her? Na die werden ja künstlich erzeugt, der Erfinder, der Satoshi Nakamoto, genau, hat sich das so gedacht, dass er musste ja irgendwie anfangen und er wollte ja nicht, wie früher, dass das durch Gold gestützt wird, so bei vielen Währungen. Und weil er hatte ja auch keins, würde ich mal überhaupt nicht so viel. Irgendwie musste er ja loslegen und seine Idee war halt, dass man sich das berechnet und damit sich nicht einfach jeder hinsetzt und sich unendlich viele berechnet, hat er das so gestaltet, dass man Rechenaufgaben macht, die kompliziert sind und man nur manchmal was findet und dann hat man Bitcoins. Und diese Rechenaufgaben, die sind auch nicht unnötig, sondern die signieren sozusagen wieder alle Transaktionen, die im Bitcoin-Netzwerk gemacht wurden. Das sind die sogenannten Blocks. In einem Block sind die Transaktionen drin, die werden unterschrieben und wenn die Unterschrift passend ist, dann kriegt man auch wiederum Bitcoins dafür. Das läuft aber aus irgendwann. Das ist alles vorberechnet, irgendwann gibt es keine mehr. Das ist sozusagen endlich.
Also momentan ist es noch so, es gibt diese Bücher mit der Buchhaltung quasi, die also digital erstellt werden. Und momentan, wenn ich daran mitarbeite, dass diese Bücher erstellt werden, kriege ich als Belohnung...
Genau, inzwischen zwar sehr wenig, aber früher als er angefangen hat, 2009, hat man, immer wenn man einen Block gefunden hat, und in einem Block wohnen ja die Transaktionen halt signiert, hat man 50 Bitcoins bekommen.
Okay, aber wenn du sagst, das ist irgendwann vorbei, welche Motivation soll denn dann noch da sein, in Zukunft auch darauf aufzupassen, was die anderen Leute machen?
Na, irgendwann, wenn es, keine Ahnung, ich glaube bis 2100 geht das, glaube ich, mit dem Bitcoin erstellen.
Aber da ist es schon früher so.
Dann gibt es keine Bitcoins mehr, also dann werden so wenig Bitcoins ausgeschüttet, dass es eigentlich fast null ist. Aber der, der diese Blöcke signiert und findet, der kriegt alle Transaktionsgebühren, die bei diesen Transaktionen entstehen. Also wenn ich neben Dirk eine Transaktion mache, dann ist es so wie in einer echten Bank auch, dann gibt es leichte Transaktionsgebühren. Man kann die sich zurzeit selber aussuchen, man kann die sehr niedrig setzen, man kann die sehr hoch setzen. Wenn man die aber auf Null setzt, zum Beispiel, könnte es passieren, dass die Transaktion nicht stattfindet, weil der, der sich die Arbeit macht, denkt sich dann, wenn da keine Transaktionsgebühren drin sind, dann mach ich das nicht.
Ein kleines Verständnisproblem. Du hast ja gesagt, alle gucken auf die Transaktion. Aber es kriegt nur einer Geld dafür, dass er draufgeguckt hat.
Er guckt ja nicht nur drauf, er siegen jetzt ja auch. Und alle prüfen auch dessen Ergebnis, was er da abliefert, ob das stimmt.
Okay. Also sagen, es ist, okay.
Das ist sozusagen in dieser Software eingebaut. Dieser Bitcoin Klein, wenn man sich den runterlädt, da ist das gesamte Regelwerk in dieser Software drin.
Okay, also ich kann die Software gar nicht benutzen, ohne den anderen auch zuzugucken. Ich kann nämlich gar nicht entscheiden. Korrekt.
Das ist auch das Problem. Also wenn die jetzt hier unsere Hörer denken, sie wollen jetzt bei Bitcoin mitmachen und sie laden sich den Kleinen drunter, dann dauert es erst mal ein paar Stunden, weil sie müssen erst mal die letzten sechs Jahre Buchhaltung runterladen, so könnte man das nennen. Das sind zurzeit irgendwie 60 oder 70 Gigabyte. Jetzt sagen wahrscheinlich alle, na, ihr seid ja verrückt, was soll ich denn mit so viel Daten? Aber der Satoshi Nakamoto hat sich das so gedacht, dass halt die Festplatten schneller groß werden, als diese Blockchain groß wird. Und das passt auch einigermaßen.
Es gibt auch Clients, die mit einer vereinfachten Version funktionieren, die brauchen nicht die gesamte Blockchain.
Das kommt auch dazu.
Sonst gäbe es auch keine Mobiltelefon-Wallets, weil da sind nämlich keine 60 GB Platz drauf. Zumindest nicht auf meinem Telefon.
Und jetzt ist es ja aber so, dass die... Das ist ja eine virtuelle Währung, aber die erhält dann letztlich nur dadurch, dass ich meine, klar, jetzt haben wir Bits berechnet, und die kann man auch hin und her schieben, und das ist alles gut und schön, aber die wäre ja kein Geld wert, wenn ich sie nicht irgendwann umtauschen könnte in irgendwas.
Dafür gibt es ja Exchanges, so nennt man die. Da gehst du hin und sagst, ich hab hier einen Bitcoin, und der Exchange sagt, für mich ist der gerade 100 Euro wert. Dann sagst du, du bist bescheuert, ist ja viel zu wenig. Dann gehst du zu einem anderen Exchange, und der sagt dir 200, dann sagst du, ja, prima, nämlich. Das heißt, festgelegt wird der Wert nicht, sondern bestimmt der Markt einfach, Angebot und Nachfrage. Das ist übrigens mit dem Euro genauso, nur dass der Euro so viele Leute Einfluss haben, dass er nicht einfach mal so hin und her schwankt. Und bei Bitcoin ist es eigentlich nicht anders.
Ist das jetzt der Punkt, wo wir Manfred dazuholen?
Ich weiß nicht, was Manfred erzählen will.
Es geht um Bitsquare dann gleich.
Ja, weiß ich nicht.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen Manfred. Manfred ist zugeschaltet aus Spanien, wenn ich richtig informiert bin. Sehr schön. Und du arbeitest in etwas, was genau so ein Exchange ist, wie Dennis gerade gesagt hat. Kannst du mal genau erklären, was das ist und dann was du konkret machst daran?
Ja, also BitSquare ist ein dezentraler Exchange. Das ist der Hauptunterschied zu den normalen Exchanges. Das ist mehr oder weniger der erste dezentrale Exchange, wo man Bitcoin gegen nationale Währungen wie Euro oder Dollar oder was umtauschen kann, weil die normalen Exchanges funktionieren prinzipiell via Stock Exchange oder Forex Exchange. Es ist einfach prinzipiell eine Bank, die dort den Markt hat und die Käufer oder Verkäufer werden dort gematcht und die Bank verwaltet das Geld, du zahlst dein Geld ein und tauscht um und kriegst dann irgendwann das Geld wieder raus, wenn du es überweist.
Also das ist sozusagen eine zentrale Stelle.
Genau, das sind die normalen Exchanges. Und das sind eigentlich ein ziemlicher Widerspruch zu der Idee von Bitcoin, weil Bitcoin ist ja der Währungssystem und Transaktionssystem, wo diese zentralen Stellen vermieden sind. Satoshi Nakamoto hat eben bewiesen, dass es möglich ist, ohne diesen trusted third parties auszukommen. Und beim Exchange, wenn du jetzt einen Bitcoin kaufen willst, bist du aber prinzipiell angewiesen auf diese zentralen Firmen, die prinzipiell wie Banken operieren. Und BitSquare ist eben die erste Lösung, wo die User in einer dezentralen Art und Weise Bitcoin gegen Euro und andere...
Bevor wir dazu kommen, das genau erklären, wie es funktioniert, würde ich gerne wissen, ist das also das Dezentral zu gestalten? Ist das sozusagen nur so eine technische, also quasi so eine idealistische Herausforderung, weil das soll jetzt alles dezentral sein? Oder gibt es sozusagen praktische Nachteile, dass diese anderen Exchanges quasi zentral gesteuert werden?
Das Dezentrale ist eigentlich Erfolgerung vom Censorship Resistance. Also aus meiner Meinung, das teilen auch viele andere Bitcoiner, das Wesentliche von Bitcoin ist eigentlich, dass es eben Censorship Resistance ist. Es kann kein Staat oder keine Firma hergehen und kann sagen, diese Transaktion war, ja, frieren wir ein oder machen wir rückgängig. So wie es zum Beispiel damals bei Wikileaks passiert ist in Amerika, dass einfach viele oder so gut wie alle großen Payment-Firmen und Credit Card-Companies die Konten von Wikileaks eingefroren haben. Das ist bei Bitcoin nicht möglich. Das verlagert heute im Prinzip das Internet. Das ist eigentlich das, was Internet für Information ist. Und das war ja auch früher. Also vor dem Internet hat es im Prinzip nur Radio, Fernsehen und Zeitungen gegeben, um Meinungen oder Informationen auszubreiten. Und es war sehr limitiert und es war eine sehr große Hürde. Man hat nicht einfacher Journalist werden können, es haben nur wenige Leute sein können. Und dann hat es relativ wenige kleine Channels gegeben, wo man nicht sehr effektiv Information austauschen hat können. Mit Internet hat man das demokratisiert und jeder kann heute mit seinem Blog prinzipiell seine eigene Zeitung aufmachen oder sein Video.
Um zurück zu sagen, zum Geld zu kommen, das Problem an den zentralen Exchanges, was du siehst, ist, dass die sagen, haben wir dann irgendeinen Land oder einen Ort, an dem sie sitzen, und dann kann immer sozusagen eine Regierung hingehen oder wir auch immer sagen so, ne, das darfst du nicht mehr, wenn man das genug macht, gibt es sozusagen dann irgendwann keine Möglichkeit mehr, Bitcoins in, ich sag mal, echtes Geld.
Ja genau, das ist auch sehr real. Das ist in China passiert vor drei Jahren. Das hat damals einen Crash dann ausgelöst, da war Bitcoin ja schon über 1000 Dollar wert und dann ist runter, gange wieder auf Reliefs wenig. Und der Auslöser war hauptsächlich, dass die chinesische Regierung allen Banken und Finanzinstituten verboten haben, dass sie mit Bitcoin-Unternehmen oder eben Exchanges irgendwas zu tun haben. Also die Exchanges haben keine Konten machen können, die Leute haben keine chinesische Währung einbezahlen können und das war natürlich der Markt uns hier eingefroren. Und dieser Gateway vom jetzigen Geld, vom nationalen Geld zur Cryptocurrency ist natürlich sehr kritisch. Und das ist in meiner Meinung eine Hilles-Ferse fürs ganze Bitcoinsystem. Weil ja, manche Staaten auf jeden Fall in Bitcoin eine Konkurrenz sehen, weil sie mit Bitcoin eben keine Kontrolle und Überwachung und nicht die Kontrolle übers Geld haben. Und die wollen das vermeiden und Druck ausüben auf den Exchanges, das ist der einfachste Weg.
Dann haben wir jetzt schon mal eine Motivation dafür, warum es sinnvoll sein kann, das noch irgendwie anders zu gestalten. Wir klären gleich, wie das gehen kann, weil das ist eine sehr interessante Frage, weil das Geld muss ja dann irgendjemand tatsächlich auszahlen. Wie das funktioniert, klären wir gleich. Dirk, da hat das noch einen.
Ja, das war genau meine Frage. Wie funktioniert BitSquare?
Das klären wir gleich. Vorher hören wir noch eine Musik von den Paper Thieves. I'd like to stay und dann sind wir gleich hier wieder da und erklären, wie man Dezentral aus Bits Euro macht. Zwei Sprechstunden. Das war's für heute. Und damit herzlich willkommen zurück im Chaos Radio im Blue Moon, wo es heute um digitale Währung geht oder um digitales Geld oder um wie man Dinge, die etwas wert sind, von einer Position zur anderen verschifft, ohne dass man tatsächlich Münzen benutzt. Wir haben schon über Plastikkarten geredet. Wir haben schon ein bisschen über Online-Dienste, die auch irgendwie Geld verschippern geredet und jetzt als letztes über Bitcoin haben schon kurz erklärt, was das genau ist. Und jetzt wollen wir sozusagen, nachdem wir erklärt haben, dass das ein System ist, wie man Online-Werte, also abstrakte Werte sozusagen, erstmal so ein Bitcoin ist einfach nur sozusagen was Digitales verschifft, wollen wir jetzt genau erklären, wie man damit wieder zu, ich sage mal in Anführungszeichen, echtem Geld kommt. Dann haben wir schon gelernt, na ja, also wenn das eine zentrale Instanz macht, ein sogenannter Exchange, dann kann das gefährlich sein, weil dann eine Start oder vielleicht auch eine dickere Firma sagen kann, ne, das darfst du nicht mehr, geh weg. Deswegen gibt es die Idee, dass man das dezentral macht. Wir begrüßen nochmal alle Anwesenden, das sind Dennis, Dirk, Christian und Manfred. Hallo und guten Abend. Das kam noch ein bisschen schwungvoll, beim nächsten Opener haben wir noch ein bisschen Zeit. So, also die Idee ist, Bitcoin ist ja sowas Dezentrales, also alle, die sich diese Software installiert haben, arbeiten daran, dass das Bitcoin-System konsistent bleibt und gucken drauf, wer überweist gerade wem was, aber wenn man das wieder zu anderem Geld machen will, dann muss man zu einer zentralen Stelle gehen, die irgendwo tatsächlich einen Ort hat. So, und jetzt gibt's Manfred von BitSquare, der sagt, nein, das geht auch anders, wir können das auch dezentral machen. So Manfred, was würden Sie jetzt alle fragen, wie geht das?
Ja, im Prinzip folgt das recht ähnlichen Prinzipien wie Bitcoin selbst, also es verwendet ein peer-to-peer-Netzwerk. Anders als Bitcoin verwenden wir Tor, es integriert in der Application, also der User muss da nichts installieren. Und Tor, ihr habt vorher schon über Tor geredet, meine Meinung zu Tor ist, es ist einfach ein Privacy- und Security-Layer zum Internet. Das ist im Prinzip wie HTTPS, was jeder verwendet, wenn er zur Bank-Webpage surft. Ähnlich ist eigentlich Tor. Es hat nur bessere und höhere Sicherheit und Privacy. Aber zurück zum Thema. Ja, weil der User das installiert hat, ist er verbunden mit allen anderen BitSquare-Usern und kann entweder ein Offer machen, dass er jetzt Bitcoin gegen Euro zum Beispiel umtauschen will, oder er kann ein bestehendes Offer nehmen, was er in einer Liste in der Application dann sieht. Ja, dann sobald er eben einen Trade startet mit einem anderen User, muss der, der den Bitcoin verkaufen will, muss den Bitcoin einzahlen auf eine spezielle Adresse, das ist eine Multisig-Adresse. Das ist etwas Spezielles im Bitcoin, das ist im Prinzip so etwas wie eine Lockbox. Da kann man definieren, wie viele Eigentümer mehr oder weniger es gibt für diese Adresse und wie viele Eigentümer man braucht, um das Geld, das auf der Adresse ist, auszuzahlen. Wir verwenden eine 2-of-3-Multisig, das heißt, man braucht mindestens zwei der drei Beteiligten, damit man das Geld wieder rausbekommt. Normalerweise sind das die zwei Leute, die den Exchange machen. Wenn am Schluss alles gut gegangen ist, dann können die beide das vereinbaren, dass das Geld dann ausbezahlt wird, auf den, der das Bitcoin kaufen will. Wenn irgendwas schief geht, entweder aus technischen Problemen oder weil einer den anderen betrügen will oder die Bank Probleme gemacht hat bei der Überweisung, dann gibt es diese dritte Person, das ist ein Arbitrator oder ein Schiedsrichter oder Customer Care Agent, der sich dann den Fall anschaut und der dann mit beiden kommuniziert und der muss dann herausfinden, was schiefgegangen ist und wem das Geld zusteht.
Ich versuche mal zusammenzufassen. Also jemand hat einen Bitcoin, also man kann die Währung unterteilen, wenn du das nur für theoretisch nennen willst. Jemand hat einen Bitcoin und schreibt quasi in der Software, was so eine Art Auktionsplattform für virtuelle Währung zu sein scheint, schreibt, ich möchte einen Bitcoin verkaufen. Wer bietet mir dafür 100 Euro? Und dann kann ich sagen, okay, ich mache das. Oder es ist umgedreht, ich sage, ich habe 100 Euro. Wer will mir dafür einen Bitcoin verkaufen? Und dann kommunizieren wir über die App und dann überweise ich, also dann sagt der Typ, ich zahle das ein auf so eine Art Sicherheitskonto. Ich überweise dem auf herkömmlichen Wege irgendwie diese 100 Euro. Und dann sagen beide, das ist okay. Und dann wird mir der Bitcoin übertragen.
Ja genau, also die Überweisung von der Fiat-Währung, also von Euro zum Beispiel, die geht dann ganz normal klassisch über die Banken. Also du bekommst über die Software die Kontonummer vom Bitcoin-Käufer und gehst dann auf deinen Online-Konto, machst die Überweisung, machst eine Confirmation in der Application, die Nachricht muss dann nachschauen, ob er das Geld erhalten hat. Das kann natürlich leider ein paar Tage dauern, weil die Banken jetzt nicht langsam sind, was völlig unverständlich ist heutzutage. Aber sobald der Bitcoin-Verkäufer die Euro erhalten hat, bestätigt er das in der Software und damit wird dann diese Auszahlungstransaktion gemacht von diesen gesperrten Bitcoins. Und der Bitcoin-Käufer bekommt seine Bitcoins. Das ist eigentlich der Basis.
Jetzt hast du aber gesagt, es gibt so eine Art Schiedsrichter, der guckt, ob das alles in recht der Dinge geht und wenn er irgendwie beschissen ist oder technische Probleme, kann er es erklären. Wo sitzt dieser Schiedsrichter? Wer ist das?
Ja, das ist momentan... Also das wird auch ein dezentrales System sein, das ist momentan noch nicht implementiert, weil das noch ein bisschen aufwendig ist. Aber prinzipiell kann jeder so ein Arbitrator werden. Der muss aber einen gewissen Geldbetrag hinterlegen, auch in so einem Multisig. Und es gibt eine gewisse Hierarchie von Arbitratern. Also die Arbitrator, die am meisten Geld hinterlegt haben und die am längsten dabei sind, also die am meisten Reputation haben, die haben dann ein höheres Gewicht. Die sind zum Beispiel die Keyholder von diesem Multisig, wo dieses Depostet einbezahlt wird von neuen Arbitrator. Und der Arbitrator schaut sich das an, hat ein bisschen wie ein Customer Care Job. Also der bekommt ein gewisses Rulebook, wie er arbeiten muss und was er befolgen muss. Ja, also das ist noch nicht ganz geklärt, aber für BitSquare ist eine neue Organisationsform geplant, also eine Art virtuelle Aktiengesellschaft. Also Decentralized Autonomous Organization ist der Begriff, der in der Kryptowelt dafür verwendet wird. Das ist ein nächstes Subprojekt, das wahrscheinlich bald entwickelt wird. Und damit werden alle Leute, die für BitSquare arbeiten, mit der Eigentümer vom Projekt und bekommen dann die Trading Fees bezahlt als Lohn. Also sind einfach wie bei einer AG-Shareholder. Und desto mehr Share sie haben, desto höher reingenehm werden sie bekommen. Und die Leute, die dafür arbeiten, bekommen für die Arbeit neue Shares ausbezahlt.
Das heißt sozusagen, im Prinzip, wenn ich mich da hinsetze und diesen Job mache, dann kriege ich dafür Geld aus Transaktionsgebühren. Jetzt ist ja der Mensch grundsätzlich schlecht und da würde ich mir denken, so okay, wenn ich so was mache, dann spreche ich mich einfach mit jemanden ab, der Bitcoin verkauft, bin ja selber Arbitrader und dann kann man da schön Beschiss machen.
Genau, aber dafür musst du eben am Anfang relativ hohe Summe hinterlegen. Das wären so ungefähr 5-10 Bitcoins sind. Das sind 2-5.000 Euro und die werden, die sind gelockt mit den Keys von den Arbitratern mit der höchsten Reputation. Das sind auch Arbitrater, die mit dem Projekt direkt verbunden sind. Das bin ich zum Beispiel. Also ich werde nicht irgendeinen, einen User betrügen und mein eigenes Projekt ruinieren oder andere Leute.
Wer weiß. Okay, aber man muss schon so eine Art Grundvertrauen in das Projekt haben, wenigstens.
Ja, ich glaube, es erledigt sich wirklich, weil das, was der Arbitrator maximal stehlen kann bei einem Trade, also die Trades sind immer limitiert auf momentan maximal zwei Bitcoin. Das sind ungefähr 1000 Euro. Das heißt, maximal 1000 Euro stehlen, wenn dann der zweite Arbitrator, der schaut sich das an. Also wenn...
Also ich kann sagen, ich kann nie mehr Euro klauen in einem Mal, als ich eh eingezahlt und hinterlegt habe.
Genau, du wirst auf jeden Fall verlieren. Und dann wird, wenn ihm solche, also der andere Trader, der sich ungerecht behandelt fühlt, der wird sich dann beschwerden. Dann werden sich diese High Reputation Arbitrator, den Fall noch mehr anschauen, wenn die draufkommen. Der Arbitrator hat betrogen, verliert erst ein ganzes Deposit und hat viel mehr verloren, wie er gewinnen kann. So, das ist das Grundkonzept. Detail sind dann noch komplex auf jeden Fall, aber da haben wir nicht die Zeit dazu wahrscheinlich.
Ich wollte noch kurz fragen, wieso benutzt ihr Tor und was ist der Effekt, Tor zu nutzen? Also ist es ein Hidden Service BitSquare oder?
Ja, eigentlich der Hauptgrund, warum ich, ich hab früher andere das Peer-to-Peer-Netzwerk verwendet, der Distributed Hashtable, das hat aber leider nie gut funktioniert im echten Internet, weil es, also die große Hürde für Peer-to-Peer-Netzwerke sind die Firewalls und die Natural Versions, also die Probleme, die man mit den verschiedenen Setups von verschiedenen Computern hat, dass man erreichbar ist für andere User. Und ich wollte nicht, dass die Leute dann selbst irgendwas konfigurieren müssen mit einem Router oder so, damit sie die Software verwenden können. Das heißt, ich brauchte eine Lösung, die einfach zum installieren ist und funktioniert. Und Tor ist einfach eine super Lösung, weil die kommen über jede Firewall.
Also diese Trading-Plattform ist gar keine Webseite, sondern das ist die Software, die über Tor miteinander kommuniziert?
Es ist eine Desktop-Application. Es ist in Java implementiert und Tor ist integriert in der Application. Man muss nicht Tor installieren oder irgendwas konfigurieren. Das kommt alles mit der Application und bei Default hat man Tor. Und dadurch ist man nicht mit seiner IP-Adresse sichtbar zu irgendein anderem Netzwerk. Man hat eigentlich maximale Privacy-Themen mit der jetzigen IP-Adresse, mehr oder weniger. Ja, maximale ist nicht mehr relativ, aber das ist wahrscheinlich eine der besten Lösungen für Privacy-Themen.
Dennis hat auch noch eine Frage.
Ja, und zwar, wenn du meinst, hier du bist der Oberarbitrator, ist das dann nicht das ganze System doch wieder so ganz schön zentral?
Ja, ich bin nicht der Oberarbitrator. Das führt dann in eine Gruppe. Es wird einfach so eine Hierarchie sein. Und es ist ein bisschen ähnlich wie das legale System mit den Supreme Courts, mit den obersten Gerichtshöfen, irgendwo.
Aber das ist doch dann sehr zentral, weil dann der oberste Gerichtshof ist sehr, sehr zentral.
Genau, der Trade selbst, der Arbitrator, weiß gar nichts davon. Er bekommt, er ist nur quasi, es wird nur sein Key verwendet zum Erstellen dieser Multisig, aber er ist nicht aktiver Bestandteil vom Trade. Nur wenn ein Problem auftaucht, dann brauchen wir sichere Lösungen, wie wir das Problem lösen. Und da ist dann der Dezentralisationsaspekt, ja, wir haben zumindest noch keine bessere Lösung gefunden, wie diese, dass wir so ein hierarchisches System haben. Und irgendwo muss man aufhören. Natürlich könnte man dann irgendwo hergehen.
Aber noch so sagen, als letzter Frage, wie viele sozusagen oberste wird es geben?
Also Details, nachdem dieses dezentrale System noch nicht implementiert ist, die sind noch nicht alle völlig ausgearbeitet. Also das Grundkonzept ist, dass es eine größere Gruppe ist von 10 bis 20 Leuten, die teilweise für BitSquare arbeiten oder die teilweise persönlich bekannt sind, wo ich einfach weiß, die sind keine Betrüger. Und die Incentives funktionieren ja, weil diese Leute, die für BitSquare arbeiten, wenn die jetzt irgendwo andere Users kämen, erzeugen ja viel mehr Schaden, wie sie eigentlich verdienen über die Plattform, wenn sie dafür arbeiten und das Projekt erfolgreich wird.
Wir müssen leider zum Schluss kommen, weil wir sagen noch ein paar andere Themen, schauen wir mal an. Einen spannenden Ansatz auf jeden Fall zu sagen, dass man die Verwandlung ins, wie heißt es, Viat-Geld, also das echte Geld, auch dezentral organisieren kann.
Ich hatte noch eine ganz kurze Frage.
Wir haben gerade jetzt mit der letzten Version Statistiken eingebaut, weil es auch nicht so trivial in einem peer-to-peer-System ist. Und es wird aber ein bisschen dauern, bis das alle Use abgedetet haben, bis wir halbwegs vernünftige Statistiken haben. Aber es ist noch, also seit April ist es live und es ist halt noch in Bootstrapping, also kann jetzt nicht wirklich...
Wie viel Volumen meinst du, wie viele Bitcoins da umgesetzt werden? Na gut, sind wir dann sehr gespannt. Manfred, dir auf jeden Fall vielen Dank für die Erläuterung. So, und dann haben wir tatsächlich noch einen Hörer anruf und zwar den Christopher aus Oranienburg. Hallo und guten Abend, Christopher.
Moin leschön.
Du hattest eine Frage zu Bitcoin noch.
Zu dem Manfred direkt, zu seinem Projekt hatte ich eigentlich eine Frage.
Ist der Manfred noch da?
Deutschland ist ja nun mal die größte Exchange zurzeit Bitcoin.de. Die haben ja einen Pakt, sag ich jetzt mal, mit der Speedo-Bank eingegangen. Dadurch ist es möglich, sozusagen Bitcoin als Blitzüberweisung auszuführen, was mir persönlich sehr gut gefällt, weil ich hab schon oft das Erlebnis gehabt, man überweist, das dauert, das dauert, das dauert, der Bitcoin fällt ins Unermessliche, dann hat man ihn endlich und ist nur noch die Hälfte wert. Ist da im Plan irgendwie eine Möglichkeit zu finden, auch so etwas zu gestalten?
Also längerfristig wollen wir Bank oder Payment Provider APIs integrieren, aber da kommen leider nur ganz moderne Firmen in Frage und da gibt es halt nur ganz wenige im Bankenbereich oder im Paymentbereich. Also ich kenne nur OKB und Perfect Money, die APIs anbieten, wo man in der Application dann direkt einen Kontauch für Euro oder sowas hat und dann die Transaktion automatisieren kann. Dann kann alles viel schneller ablaufen, weil dann nicht der User handysch irgendwie online gehen muss und bestätigen muss und so weiter. Und wenn der nicht am Computer sitzt, dauert es ein paar Stunden. Leider mit normalen Bankengebieten keine APIs anbieten und ich glaube, das wird auch nicht in Kürze passieren. Also da bin ich sehr pessimistisch, weil ich meine, die könnten das seit mehr als 10 Jahren machen, wie alle normalen Internetprojekte oder Firmen das machen, aber das Leben halt in 80 Jahren. Und das sehe ich auch keine große Bewegung. Immer mit modernen Payment- oder Fintech-Firmen, wie diese Number 26, das ist auf jeden Fall interessant. Die werden wir vermutlich auch bald integrieren und dann mehr und mehr versuchen, dass dann die Leute dazwischen, weil man kann den Transfer von Fiat um einiges beschleunigen, wenn es die gleiche Firma oder die gleiche Bank ist. Dann geht es alles wirklich instant, wie bei OKB. Oder eben wenn es auch die gleiche Bank ist, geht es in manchen Ländern zumindest auch instant. Und das werden wir auf jeden Fall mehr unterstützen. Momentan haben wir halt nur die wichtigsten Sachen, wie SEPA und nationalen Payment-Transfers, damit das weltweit funktioniert.
Ich glaube, der Bedarf, der Bitcoin Nutzer, ich kenne jetzt nicht viele Bitcoin Nutzer, ich glaube, der Großteil der Bitcoin Nutzer legt schon Wert darauf, dass diese Transaktionen schnell über die Bühne gehen. Von daher glaube ich, dass es wünschenswert ist. Ansonsten unterstütze ich die Idee, also das wird super, ich bin nochmal so am Rande.
Also bei OKB, bei diesen Payment-Methoden, wo wir wissen, dass sie instant möglich sind, ist es nur ein Tag Zeitfenster im BitSquare, wo die User die Transaktion abwickeln müssen. Ansonsten geht es dann zum Arbitrator. Und der, der zu langsam war, verliert dann ein bisschen was an Geld. Aber leider bei normalen Banken wie bei SEPA kann es teils 3-4 Tage dauern. Und wenn es eine lange Woche ist, dauert es insgesamt 7 Tage. Da sind wir leider an dieses alte System gebunden und können nichts Besseres machen, weil sonst die liefern.
Alles klar, Christoph, ich hoffe, das hat deine Frage beantwortet.
Ich glaube, ab 2017, vielleicht aber auch ein Jahr später, ich bin mir nicht so sicher, gibt es auch neue Auflagen für die Banken, dann muss das alles sehr, sehr schnell gehen mit den Überweisungen.
Was heißt sehr schnell? 24 Stunden? 6? 2? Eine?
Minuten.
Minuten?
Ja, oder noch schneller.
Weiß jemand von euch, warum das so lange dauert? Also hat die Bank irgendwas davon?
Die verwenden teils wirklich noch Mainframes. Ich hab zwei Programmiererkennende von der Uni. Einer hat eben noch Mainframe, der war noch Mainframe-Programmierer. Er war wahrscheinlich der einzige, den sie gefunden haben. Und die Bank der einzige Job, den er gefunden hat. Die verwenden wirklich noch Systeme aus den 70, 80 Jahren. Das ist halt super langsam. Das andere Hauptproblem ist, glaube ich, Chargeback. Dass das Settlement einfach sehr kompliziert ist, weil man nie sicher ist, wenn das Geld wirklich sicher ist und nicht zurückgefordert werden kann. Ich glaube bei SEPA hat man ein halbes Jahr. Das ist natürlich ein Wahnsinn.
Alles klar, verrückt. Hoffen wir, dass es irgendwann mal schneller wird. Ich würde es mir über uns auch wünschen. So, Mainframe, dann aber jetzt wirklich vielen Dank und viel Glück mit BitSquare noch. Ich bin sehr gespannt, wo das hingeht. So, und jetzt habt ihr euch vielleicht gefragt, der Richter hat doch jedes Mal, wenn die Sendung aufgemacht, auch den Christian begrüßt. Warum ist der denn eigentlich hier? Naja, also es gibt, jetzt sag ich wieder was, was wahrscheinlich gleich auch wieder großen Aufschrei verursachen wird. Aber in meiner Wahrnehmung, als jemand, der nicht allzu viel Ahnung hat, es gibt sozusagen ein Projekt und das kommt bei mir so an, wie das ist jetzt das neue Bitcoin. Das heißt Ethereum oder Ethereum oder irgendwie so und ist anscheinend auch was, was wie Bitcoin funktioniert, so ist es bei mir zumindest angekommen. Christian, du arbeitest an diesem Projekt mit, bist damit involviert. Was genau ist das? Ist es wie Bitcoin oder nicht?
Also es benutzt die die gleiche Technologie, die gleiche grundlegende Technologie, also diese Blockchain Technologie, die wir vorhin auch erklärt haben.
Also Blockchain heißt dieses sagen, jemand macht was und alle gucken zu und schreiben auf, was er gemacht hat.
Genau so ist es ja. Aber Bitcoin hat als Anwendungsfall sozusagen Überweisungen tätigen und da funktioniert es auch sehr gut und das wollen wir auch gar nicht ersetzen. Was Ethereum macht ist, dem ganzen System noch eine Datenbank hinzufügen und Programme hinzufügen. Wir hatten ja vorhin das Beispiel mit dem Buch, das in der Bank liegt. Man muss der Bank vertrauen, dass er dieses Buch richtig führt. Bei Ethereum gibt es auch so ein Buch, das dezentral verwaltet wird. Da kann man nicht nur Kontostände damit verwalten, sondern es ist eine richtige Datenbank. Software kann auf diese Datenbank zugreifen und die Daten verändern, mit der Daten etwas machen. Während die Software das tut, können alle zuschauen und kontrollieren, dass das mit richtigen Dingen funktioniert.
Was Bitcoin eigentlich macht, ist, es stellt eine Liste mit Zahlen und sagt dann, also Zahl 1 gehört jetzt User X, Zahl 2 gehört User Y, Zahl 3 gehört User und so weiter und so fort. Alle gucken zu, alle schreiben beim Anruf, aber man weiß im Prinzip kann man nur das machen, man kann diese Blöcke, Briefmarken, Zahlen hin und her schieben. Jetzt sagst du, Serum ist so was ähnliches, aber da stecken einfach mehr Daten drin.
Also vielleicht kann ich mal ein paar Beispiele geben, was man machen kann und zwar genauso, man kann wie bei Bitcoin auch die Währung verschieben. Es kann sich aber auch jeder ganz einfach eine eigene Währung erzeugen, die dann auf diesem System funktioniert und man kann Daten verwalten, wie zum Beispiel ein Grundbuch, ein Grundstückregister. Das heißt, ich kann in diese Datenmark rein schreiben, also wenn ein Staat zustimmt, das Grundbuch so zu verwalten, dann könnte man das über dieses System machen und man kann eben auch das durch Programme verwalten lassen. Und dann kann man beispielsweise sagen, es gibt ein Programm, das auf Ethereum läuft, das komplett dezentral verwaltet wird, das eine Auktion darstellt. Das heißt, ich kann dezentral Auktionen durchführen lassen über diese Daten in der Datenbank.
Ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich verstehe es immer noch. Ich wollte gerade sagen, verstehst du das?
Ja, also ich probiere es mal. Und zwar ist ja bei Bitcoin ist es so, da werden ja auch nicht die Zahlen verwaltet, sondern jede Transaktion ist so ein kleines Skript, was sagt, diese Bitcoin bitte von da nach da schieben. Das heißt, diese Skripte sind sehr transaktionsbasiert. Wenn ich das richtig verstehe, weil ich kenne mich mit Ethereum auch nicht so aus, dann bei Ethereum sind auch Skripte, aber die sind wesentlich komplexer und man kann da auch noch andere Sachen mit machen als nur Transaktionen oder Zahlen verschieben. Ist das ungefähr richtig?
Also man hat einen Key-Value-Store, man kann Sachen abspeichern.
Ich liebe es, wenn das ein paar... Alles sogar einfach zum Key-Value-Store. Also okay, ich versuche es nochmal zu verstehen. Ich versuche es mal andersrum zu erklären oder ich versuche es mal andersrum zu verstehen. Also es gibt ja Programme so in der normalen Welt. Also wir beschreiben Programme sind sozusagen Teilen von Code und die werden dann ausgeführt von einem Computer. Und Ethereum ist das jetzt sozusagen, es gibt ein Programm, aber das ist da irgendwie hinterlegt und dann gucken alle, ob es das macht, was es soll oder so?
Genau, also durch diese Technologie ist es praktisch so, dass sozusagen ein globaler Computer geschaffen wird, der von jedem benutzt werden kann und der von jedem auch kontrolliert werden kann.
Also jeder kann da ein Programm reinstellen in diesen globalen Computer und dann ist es nicht Distributed Computing, sondern Decentralized Computing. Das heißt, jeder Rechner im Netzwerk führt das gleiche Programm zur gleichen Zeit auf gleiche Art und Weise aus und das Ergebnis wird dann auf die gleiche Art und Weise von all diesen Rechnern in einen Block getan und der, der den Zuschlag kriegt, dass sein Block genommen wird, der Block landet dann in der Blockchain und da stehen dann all die Daten, also der State von dem Programm steht da dann drin.
Ok, also als Beispiel, es gibt ein Programm, das rechnet aus, wer der schlauste Mensch im ganzen Land ist.
Man könnte ein Voting, ein Voting ist glaube ich ein gutes Beispiel.
Darf ich nochmal so etwas zufassen? Ok, es gibt ein Programm, das findet raus sozusagen, dass er rechnet, wer ist der schlauste Mensch im ganzen Land. Wenn das nur auf meinem Rechner läuft, dann sagt Marcus Richter, völlig klar, dann ist sozusagen berechtigter Zweifel, dass er sagt, ja, vielleicht hat er das Programm beeinflusst, das stimmt eigentlich nicht so. Was Ethereum macht, ist, es schickt das Programm auf jeden Rechner der Teilnehmenden, stellt also sicher, dass auf jedem Rechner das Programm genauso abläuft, wie es abgegeben wurde und vergleicht dann die Ergebnisse aller Computer, die das Programm ausgeführt haben und sagt dann, die kriegen alle Marcus Richter raus, das Ergebnis muss stimmen.
Nee, die vergleichen auch nicht mal. Die müssen gar nicht miteinander vergleichen, weil die kriegen alle das gleiche Ergebnis raus. Und wenn da Programm dabei ist, was ein anderes Ergebnis rausfindet, dann ist das nicht der echte Ethereum-Client oder bei Bitcoin, das ist kein echter Bitcoin-Client und dann löst sich das vom Netzwerk ab und macht nicht mehr mit.
Okay, aber dadurch, dass das Programm auf jedem Rechner durchgeführt wird, das heißt, der Ergebnis, deswegen wird das Ergebnis dann als korrekt angenommen.
Genau, also ich meine, bei herkömmlichen Web-Server-Software, wenn ich bei Google irgendwie ein Dokument hoch lade, dann lade ich das hoch, dann läuft auf dem Google-Server natürlich auch Software und ich kann aber nicht nachvollziehen, was diese Software in meinem Dokument macht, ob das Dokument irgendwie abgeändert wird. Und bei Ethereum ist es eben so, dass es keinen einzelnen Server gibt, auf dem diese Software läuft, sondern es läuft verteilt auf allen gleichzeitig und damit kann jeder nachvollziehen, was passiert und auch sichergehen, dass genau das passiert, was man denkt.
Damit alle wieder auf dem gleichen Stand sind.
Also jeder muss ja wissen, so eine Art sichere Cloud, also transparente Cloud, weil jeder sehen kann, was darin vorgeht. Aber zumindest eine, wo nichts gefälscht werden kann. Also wo ich dann immer sicher sein kann, okay, was ich da raus bekomme, ist sozusagen das, was ich reingetan habe. Und wenn nicht, dann sehe ich, was verändert wurde.
Genau.
Ja, Mann, jetzt muss ich jetzt ein bisschen... So, ich muss jetzt erst mal sacken lassen. Die höre wahrscheinlich auch. Deswegen gibt es jetzt eine kleine Musik von Ronnie Friedman, die heißt Arms. Und dann reden wir weiter über Ethereum, den Supercomputer in der Cloud. Ha, ich hab's nochmal gesagt. Okay, kannst du gleich nochmal richtig erklären.
Ja.
Bundeskanzlerin Merkel hat die jüngsten Terroranschläge in Deutschland als zivilisatorischen Tabubruch bezeichnet. Offensichtlich wollen die Terroristen den Zusammenhalt der Gesellschaft zerstören, sagte die Kanzlerin in ihrer vorgezogenen Sommerpressekonferenz. Deutschland werde aber auch weiterhin politisch verfolgten Asyl gewähren. Die Kanzlerin kündigte auch einen neuen Punkteplan gegen islamistischen Extremismus an. Dazu soll ein besseres Frühwarnsystem vor möglichen Radikalisierungen gehören. Und es sollen Vorbereitungen getroffen werden, dass die Bundeswehr bei großen Terroranschlägen auch im Inland eingesetzt werden kann. Auch die bayerische Landesregierung verschärft nach den drei Gewalttaten innerhalb von einer Woche ihre Sicherheitspolitik. So sollen bis 2020 insgesamt 2000 neue Polizisten eingestellt und die Videoüberwachung z.B. an Bahnhöfen ausgeweitet werden. Außerdem wird der Wunsch nach einer Grundgesetzänderung formuliert. Dadurch soll der Einsatz der Bundeswehr im Inland bei Anschlaggefahren erleichtert werden. Zwischen der Türkei und Deutschland bahnt sich neuer Streit an. Die Türkei fordert von Deutschland 4500 Anhänger der Gülen-Bewegung auszuliefern. Präsident Erdogan macht den Prädigal Gülen für den Putschversuch vor zwei Wochen verantwortlich. Tausende mutmaßliche Anhänger wurden seitdem in der Türkei festgenommen oder ihre Ämter beim Militär, in der Justiz oder im Medienbereich enthoben. Das Verhältnis zwischen Deutschland und der Türkei ist bereits durch die Armenien-Resolution des Bundestages stark belastet. Darin wird das Massaker an den Armenien im Osmanischen Reich als Völkermord bezeichnet. Fußball-Bundesliga ist Hertha BSC, ist nach 6, 5 Jahren zurück auf der europäischen Fußballbühne. Die Berliner gewannen das Hinspiel in der dritten Runde der Europa League Qualifikation gegen das dänische Team von Brönnspi IF mit 1 zu 0. Das Siegtor schoss Ibisevic in der 28. Minute. Das Rückspiel findet am 4. August in Kopenhagen statt. Die aktuellen Temperaturen liegen in Berlin Marzahn bei 19, in Tegel bei 21 Grad. Küritz hat 17 Grad, Cottbus 18 Grad, Manchnow 19 Grad und Ludwigsfelde 20 Grad. In der Nacht ziehen von Südwesten vereinzelte Schauer oder Gewitter ran. Teilweise sind auch kräftige Starkregen mit dabei und es kühlt sich ab auf bis zu 16 Grad. Morgens lassen dann die Schauer nach. Es lockert auf und es wird recht freundlich mit Sonne und Wolken im Wechsel bei maximal 26 Grad. Erst am Abend kann es dann wieder neue Schauer geben. Mit dem Stadtverkehr Berlin in Charlottenburg. Die Kahnstraße zwischen New-Achimsthaler-Straße und Fasanenstraße ist gesperrt. Ein Kran-Einsatz ist dort bis morgen früh um 3 Uhr im Gange. Und in Friedrichshain an der Ostbahn in Höhe am Vrietzner Bahnhof ist ebenfalls ein Kran im Einsatz. Außerdem gibt es eine Nachtbaustelle und dort ist eine Sperrung bis um 5 Uhr früh. Außerdem gibt es immer noch Sperrungen wegen der Überschwemmungen. In Gesundbrunn ist der Gleimtunnel betroffen und in Schöneberg die Hohenstaufenstraße zwischen Martin Luther und Münchner Straße. In Brandenburg, Vorsicht auf der A20 Rostock Richtung Berlin, im Kreuz Uckermark zwischen Prenzlau-Süd und Kreuz Uckermark sind Leute auf der Standspur. Dort bitte aufpassen. Und auf der A24 Hamburg Richtung Berlin zwischen Dreieck-Wittstock-Dosse und Dreieck-Hafelland ist ein Schwertransporter unterwegs und darf nicht überholt werden. Ansonsten überall gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn ihr Fritz im Live- oder Musikstream hören wollt, dann geht doch mal auf fritz.de slash streambox.
Hallo und willkommen zurück zu einer letzten halben Stunde Chaosradio im Blumen auf Fritz, wo es heute um digitales Geld geht. Also eigentlich, wie wir mittels dieses Internets, von dem wir mal reden und was ich bestimmt gar nicht durchsetzen wird, Währungsrepräsentationen von einem Punkt zum anderen verschieben können und noch ein bisschen mehr, wie ich gerade gelernt habe. Wir haben schon geredet über wie man Kreditkarten sozusagen in Zukunft, in welche Geräte man die reinstecken kann, was mit den Dingen ist, mit so Online-Diensten, die Portale sind, wo man sein Geld verschieben kann und die das irgendwie bei sich behalten, über Bitcoins und jetzt über Ethereum oder Ethereum oder das haben wir noch gar nicht geredet. Wie spricht man das denn eigentlich wirklich aus Dennis, Dirk und Christian? Wie heißt das?
Im Englischen würde ich Ethereum sagen, im Deutschen kann man Ethereum sagen oder Ethereum oder... Ich spreche darüber nicht so viel, aber auf Deutsch deswegen.
Die Währung heißt dann Ether, glaube ich.
Also die eine Währung. Man kann ja mehrere Währungen machen, habe ich gelernt schon.
Es gibt eine Hauptwährung, deren Hauptzweck ist, diese Transaktionsgebühren zu bezahlen, die bei Ethereum genauso anfangen oder auf eine ähnliche Art und Weise anfangen, wie bei Bitcoin.
Okay, wir haben ja schon gelernt, dass Ethereum nicht nur eine Währung ist, sondern es ist quasi eine Art großer Computer, wo alle, die bei Ethereum mitmachen, das Programm einmal bei sich laufen lassen. Dadurch hat man das Ergebnis mehrfach ausgerechnet und weiß dann auch, dass es stimmt. Also dass da kein Schmuck passiert ist. Was macht man damit jetzt? Gibt es da schon Anwendungszwecke? Ich hatte als Beispiel eine Computer-Programm rechnen, aus der ich der schlauste Mensch der Welt ist. Ich vermute, das ist nicht der Zweck für Ethereum. Was macht man damit?
Also bis jetzt? Anwendungen, die man schon so richtig in der Hand halten kann, gibt es noch nicht so richtig. Das liegt auch daran, weil so richtig nützliche Sachen brauchen immer so eine Schnittstelle in der realen Welt. Und die ist halt immer ein bisschen schwieriger, was wir ja auch bei den decentralized exchanges gesehen haben. Aber also Sachen innerhalb von Ethereum oder innerhalb der Cryptocurrency-Welt sind viel leichter zu machen. Und was zurzeit relativ beliebt ist und auch schon gemacht wird, sind so eine Art Crowdfunding mit einer Beteiligungsfunktion durch Wahlen.
Erklär, genauer.
Genau, das nennt man also decentralized autonomous organization, ist das Schlagwort. Und da geht es eben darum, dass jeder, also man schafft so einen Pool und jeder kann da sein Geld reingeben. Und abhängig von der Menge an Geld, die man reingegeben hat, hat man dann ein Stimmrecht innerhalb dieser Organisation. Und dann wird durch Wahlen bestimmt, was mit dem Geld gemacht wird, oder insgesamt, wie diese Organisation agieren soll.
Also eine Aktiengesellschaft.
Ja, Aktiengesellschaft ist eine strenge Auflage, aber es ist ähnlich zu einer Aktiengesellschaft.
Man hat nicht unbedingt Dividenden zum Beispiel. Also im Prinzip ist ja eine Firma, Leute pumpen da Geld rein, dann gehört ihnen das zu gewissen Anteilen, dann dürfen sie bestimmen, was da passiert. Warum braucht man da Ethereum dazu?
Weil jeder, also genau, bei einer Aktiengesellschaft gibt es diese Aktionärsversammlungen, aber Kleinanleger gehen da nicht hin. Das heißt, sie...
Doch, für die Schnittchen.
Im Normalfall können die ihr Stimmrecht gar nicht wahrnehmen. Bei Ethereum, das ist halt eine Software, da abstimmen ist ein Klick und da kann jeder teilnehmen.
Die können ihr Stimmrecht eben, also bei den normalen Aktiengeschaften nicht wahrnehmen, weil sie nicht dürfen oder weil es keine Rolle spielt?
Nein, weil man sich physikalisch an einen Ort begeben muss, wo man dann abstimmen kann.
Das ist für die zu aufwendig. Die Stimme ist nur ein Millionzelt Teilwert, zählt wahrscheinlich im Einzelnen eh nix, und dann irgendwo hinfahren ist Quatsch. Und da soll das umgesetzt werden, weil das ist nur ein Klick am Computer, und dann kann man das eher machen. Genau. Und das ist jetzt ein Plan, den man umsetzen will, oder das gibt es schon?
Das gibt es schon, ja.
Und wofür wurde das schon benutzt?
Oder ich sag mal, ja, also...
Das ist gerade ein Wunderpunkt.
Ja, das ist gerade so ein bisschen ein Wunderpunkt. Das ist so ein bisschen schiefgegangen, sag ich mal.
Ich bin ja großer Fan von Fehlerkultur, weil alles was schiefgegangen ist, daraus kann man was lernen. Was ist genau passiert?
Es gab einen... Also, genau, wie haben wir schon gesagt, jeder kann solche Programme erstellen, d.h. man muss Software schreiben. Und Software kann natürlich Fehler haben. Und in dieser Software gab es einen Fehler.
Also in dieser Software, die diese Gesellschaft, diesen Gesellschaftsdruck darstellt, dieses DAO, was soll das sein?
Genau so ist es.
Okay, da war ein Fehler drin, der wozu geführt hat?
Der hat dazu geführt, dass man Geld auf eine Weise abziehen konnte, die so nicht geplant war. Und das wurde dann auch getan.
Und das eigentliche Problem war, dass da auch ganz viel Geld drin steckte, womit eigentlich auch vorher keiner gerechnet hat.
Also es gibt dieses Ding, dieses Ding funktioniert, dass man sozusagen etwas von der virtuellen Währung da reintut und dann kriegt man Stimmrechnungen. Da war jetzt viel Geld drin und dann hat das jemand da rausziehen können, indem er was getan hat, indem er einfach ein fehlerhaftes Programm geschrieben hat.
Ja, also man musste das Programm, also man musste eigentlich, man musste noch ein weiteres Programm erstellen, das dann mit dem DAO-Programm interagiert hat auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise. Und es war schon relativ kompliziert, das durchzuführen.
Und dann ist was passiert?
Dann ist ein großer Teil des Geldes abgeflossen in eine, ja es ist relativ komplizierter Quelltext und es gab eine Möglichkeit, wenn man mit dem Verhalten der DAO nicht zufrieden war, konnte man sich sozusagen abspalten und eine Kind-DAO gründen. Und man konnte seinen Anteil an Geld mitnehmen in diese Kind-DAO. Und es gab, wie gesagt, einen Fehler in der Programmcode, der erlaubte, dass man mehr als seinen Anteil mitnehmen konnte.
Also rein rechtlich gesehen alles legal, was der Typ da gemacht hat.
Welches Recht windest du denn an?
Im Prinzip ist das mit dem Buchhalter jetzt passiert.
Man hat eben keine eingebrochen.
Man könnte sogar zugucken, wie das Geld abgeflossen ist.
Genau. Die ISA-Leute sagen jetzt natürlich, das war ein Fehler. Aber man kann natürlich nachträglich auch zu allen möglichen Sachen sagen, das war ein Fehler. Also wer bestimmt jetzt was ein Fehler ist und wer nicht?
Die Mehrheit. Was ist denn jetzt passiert? Dieses Geld ist abgeflossen. Ist es dann irgendwie rückgängig gemacht worden?
Und wie viel Geld reden wir denn?
Genau, also dieses The Dow hat umgerechnet 150 Millionen Dollar an.
Okay.
Also es ist ein richtig schöner Incentive, sich den Code anzugucken, ob der jetzt sicher ist. Also es war eins der teuersten Bug-Bounty-Programme, die ich kenne zumindest.
Wie viel Geld ist abgeflossen?
3, 6 Millionen IFA, das waren ein Drittel ungefähr.
Okay, also man muss immer dazu sagen, der ESA ist zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt so und so viel wert und daraus errechnet sich diese Summe. Da hat jetzt niemand irgendwie diese 50 Millionen Dollar auf dem Konto.
Ja, 50 Millionen Dollar, genau. Und die sind dann in diesem Contract gelandet, diesem abgespaltenen Contract. Und dann, der war halt noch timelocked auf 27 Tage, glaube ich.
Ist gerade abgelaufen von ein paar Tagen.
Ja, also innerhalb der 27 Tage konnte er nichts damit machen.
Das ist Teil des Systems.
Ja, genau.
Teil des Systems ist immer sozusagen...
Also das Programm war so geschrieben.
Das Programm war so geschrieben, dass man sozusagen, wenn man eine Transaktion macht, 27 Tage warten muss, bevor man davon profitiert.
Und innerhalb der 27 Tage musste jetzt eine Entscheidung gefällt werden, nämlich die Entscheidung darüber, ob man das einfach so weiterlaufen lässt. Das wäre die, also nichts tun, wäre die eine Möglichkeit gewesen. Dann hätte, ja gut, erst mal nicht die Konsequenzen. Die andere Möglichkeit ist gewesen, eine Abstimmung im Netzwerk zu haben oder zu machen darüber, ob man diese 3, 6 Millionen IFA wieder zurückgibt an die Leute. Also das ist ja alles nur Software. Und basiert auf einem Konsens. Und wenn der Konsens hergestellt ist, dann kann man den auch ändern, wenn die Mehrheit der Meinung ist, dass es okay ist, den Konsens zu ändern, dann kann der geändert werden. Und genau das ist, glaube ich, letzte Woche passiert, dass die Mehrheit gesagt hat, wir wollen das rückgängig machen. Und ich weiß gar nicht, was die Details sind, aber ich nehme an, dass diese 3, 6 Millionen IFA an die Leute zurückgingen, die in The DAO eingezahlt haben. Das ist jetzt meine Vermutung.
Es wurde eine neue Software geschrieben, die eben diese Rückverteilung abgewickelt hat. Da wurde bis jetzt kein Fehler drin gefunden. Und an diese Software wurde dieses Geld einmalig überwiesen.
Aber dann ist jetzt mein Punkt, oder meine Frage wäre dann, es gibt also dieses System, das System, was eigentlich dafür da ist, dass Transaktionen, die stattfinden, nicht mehr rückgängig gemacht werden. Und jetzt ist eine Transaktion stattgefunden, da haben einfach sehr viele Leute gesagt, naja, das gefällt uns jetzt aber nicht, wir machen die doch rückgängig.
Das haben auch nicht alle gesagt, sondern nur ein paar.
Genau, aber das ist ja noch schlimmer sozusagen.
Das System stellt sicher, dass es keine kleine zentrale Stelle gibt, die Manipulationen durchführen kann oder Veränderungen durchführen kann.
Also es konnte jetzt nicht der Hersteller der Software sagen, wir machen das anders und dann ist es anders passiert, sondern es musste sich schon eine Mehrheit finden, die diese geänderte Software dann benutzt.
Das ist klar, aber was ist denn jetzt sozusagen, wenn ich etwas mache, also ich mache sozusagen eine Transaktion in diesem Ethereum, die sozusagen im Sinne des Erfinders ist, also im technischen Sinne des Erfinders, aber alle Leute finden das unmoralisch und sagen dann so, nee, das darf der nicht. Dann laufe ich ja sozusagen...
Es könnte passieren, wenn die Mehrheit sagt, das darf der nicht, dass dann genau das Gleiche passiert.
Das nennt man dann übrigens Hardfork.
Aber das ist ja das ganze System eigentlich hinfällig oder nicht?
Das ist eine relativ aufwendige Sache, so etwas durchzuführen. Und ja, das wird nicht so ohne Weiteres gemacht.
Also da wurde ja auch sehr lange gestritten. Das ist jetzt nicht so eine Entscheidung, die dir ganz leicht gefällt haben, sondern da wurde lange diskutiert und überlegt, ob sie das machen oder nicht. Und ich weiß gar nicht, gibt es da Zahlen zu dem Verhältnis, wie die abgestimmt haben?
Naja, welche Abstimmung weißt du dann? Also es gab mehrere Arten von Abstimmungen. Einmal gab es so eine Art Coin-Vote, wo jeder... Also das Hauptproblem, also vielleicht sollte man auch noch kurz drüber reden, bei diesen dezentralen Anwendungen ist es relativ schwierig, Abstimmungen personenbezogen zu machen. Also es ist schwierig zu sagen, 50% der Personen, die an diesem Netzwerk teilnehmen, haben so und so abgestimmt, weil jeder kann sich zuhause einfach eine neue Identität schaffen. Das ist ja auch gerade das Gute, dass man nicht zu einer zentralen Instanz gehen muss, um sich eine neue Identität oder neue User-Account zu erstellen.
Das ist ja bei Bitcoin auch so. Die Wallets heißt das da. Ich kann ja viele verschiedene Wallets haben.
Die Wallet ist nicht so spannend, aber die Bitcoin-Adressen, dein Konto, davon kannst du ganz viele haben.
Und bei Ethereum ist es auch so, ich kann sozusagen eine Ethereum-Instanz sein, aber ich kann auch irgendwie 20 sein, wenn ich will.
Genau. Wie macht man denn überhaupt Abstimmung, wenn das so ist?
Wenn man einen spezialisierten Contract hat, dann kann man natürlich sagen, es gibt genau diese Personen, und die können jeweils abstimmen. Aber wenn man sagen will, das ganze Netz soll abstimmen, also das ist eine offene Abstimmung, wo jeder teilnehmen kann, dann ist die naheliegende und auch mehr oder weniger die einzige praktikable Möglichkeit, dass man das vom Geldwert abhängig macht.
Was ja aber wieder schlecht ist, wenn der Attacker sich ein Drittel aller Isars geklaut hat, weil dann hat er auch ein Drittel aller Stimmen schon mal.
Hatte er ja noch nicht.
Aber der Abstimmung konnte man das nicht nutzen.
Aber führt das nicht trotzdem dafür, dass man sozusagen so ein total neoliberales System haben, wo die Leute, die am meisten Geld haben, bestimmen, wo es langgeht?
Es gibt auch andere Orten abzustimmen, also man kann auch über die Hashing-Power abstimmen, oder?
Ja, das sind auch die Leute mit dem meisten Geld.
Aber genau deswegen sag ich ja, das ist die einfache und praktikable Methode, die jetzt existiert. Aber wir arbeiten auch daran, es gibt verschiedenste Projekte, die auf Ethereum aufbauen. Und viele davon beschäftigen sich auch damit, wie man Identität regelt und man sich als Person irgendwie identifizieren kann.
Das fällt mir jetzt gerade aus, weil du hattest ja gesagt, das ist mehr als nur Währung. Aber in dem, so wie es momentan funktioniert, wirkt es auf mich tatsächlich wie etwas, was zwar mehr kann als nur Währung hin und her schieben, aber von der Bestimmungskraft immer abhängig davon ist, wer am meisten Kraft, Geld, Währung hat. Aber anders könnte man sagen, diese ganzen dezentralen Systeme, die die Transaktionen immer festschreiben und überwachen, was da passiert ist und sicherstellen, dass es die richtigen Transaktionen sind, könnte man tatsächlich für demokratische Prozesse benutzen. Gibt es da auch Ideen?
Na, es ist ja nicht anonym. Insofern ist es schwierig, das für Parlamentswahlen. Jedenfalls, wenn man den Anspruch hat, dass anonym gewählt werden können soll, dann wäre das nicht geeignet.
Es wird an solchen Sachen auch geforscht. Abstimmungen auf der Blockchain sind transparent, müssen sie ja auch sein, damit man sozusagen die Stimmauszellung nachvollziehen kann. Aber es gibt sogenannte Zero-Knowledge-Verfahren, die das Ganze trotzdem anonymisieren können. Das ist ein relativ kompliziertes mathematisches Verfahren, wo man sozusagen die Korrektheit der Stimmauszellung überprüfen kann, ohne die Stimmen wirklich zu sehen.
Das alles ist sozusagen schon noch im Experimentierstadium. Okay, da sind 150 Millionen Dollar drin. Das ist ganz schön viel, aber ich vermute, so wie sich das anhört, der Zustand der Software, ist es noch Beta oder nicht?
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es offiziell noch Beta ist.
Genau, was man auch sagen muss, die Plattform selbst ist nicht im Beta-Stadium. Und das war ja auch kein Fehler der Plattform. Aber Anwendungen, die auf der Plattform erstellt werden, da muss man immer schauen, wie...
Wie es war kein Fehler der Plattform? Das verwirrt mich jetzt doch. Wenn es kein Fehler der Plattform war, warum wurde es dann rückgängig gemacht? Was war es für ein Fehler?
Es war ein Fehler in einem Programm, das auf der Plattform erstellt wurde.
Aber wie kann das denn ein Fehler sein? Es geht doch nur darum, dass das Programm auf der Plattform ausgeführt wird und dass es sichergestellt wird, dass alle dasselbe Ergebnis rausbekommen. Das verstehe ich jetzt tatsächlich nicht so ganz.
Deswegen wurde ja abgestimmt. Viele waren mit der Meinung, das war kein Fehler. Sondern der Typ hat halt eine Schwäche ausgenutzt, aber die war ja nun mal da so rein design, hat sich einer vertan, aber es war halt Teil von dem Konstrukt und hat sich ausgenutzt.
Also der eigentliche Fehler war aber, das Programm, was in das Ethereum reingetan wurde, hat nicht so funktioniert, wie die Macher sich das gedacht haben. Aber das Ethereum hat korrekt funktioniert.
Genau.
Das verwirrt mich jetzt nochmal nachhaltig, weil das ja wirklich sagen bedeutet, dass das Ethereum eigentlich funktioniert, aber dass man sich nicht sicher ist, ob man das wirklich genauso will.
Naja, das mit dem Zurückrollen, wenn man das nicht gemacht hätte, dann wäre es schwer gewesen, Vertrauen in dieses System zu erhalten. Man kann natürlich umgekehrt... Na ja, ich meine, da wurde...
Was ich auch sagen kann, ist, dass war ein relativ großes Ereignis für die gesamte Community. Und hat wahrscheinlich auch viele so ein bisschen wachgerüttelt, sich den Programmcode nochmal genauer anzuschauen, mehr Arbeit reinzustecken und so weiter.
Also nicht nur das Programmcode von Ethereum, sondern von den Programmen, die da drauflaufen?
Genau, genau. Und hat auch viele Projekte jetzt nochmal befeuert, die so in die Richtung gehen, dass man sichere Software schreibt, dass man Software verifiziert und so weiter. Also wir haben jetzt auch ein, also das Projekt gab es schon länger, aber er hat jetzt nochmal mehr Schub bekommen, dass man formale Verifikationen betreibt. Das heißt, man benutzt Software, die andere Software verifiziert. Also mit mathematischen Verfahren prüft, ob ein Programm wirklich das tut, was man denkt, dass es tut.
Also mit Verlaub, ich würde nichts auf Ethereum machen. Das wirkt mir noch sehr, das wirkt so ein bisschen wie die Leute, die das machen, wissen vielleicht selber gar nicht mehr so ganz genau, was da passiert. Und ich finde es momentan, so wie es sich anhat, finde ich es noch ein bisschen, weiß ich nicht genau, ob das, also ich finde es total spannend als Experiment, aber ich würde zum Beispiel keine 150 Millionen Dollar rein investieren.
Ich meine, es kann ja jeder für sich entscheiden, wie viel Geld in dieses Projekt steckt. Und diese 150 Millionen, ich weiß nicht, ich meine, es waren auch sehr viele Leute beteiligt. Aber jeder hat da nur einen relativ kleinen Betrag investiert.
Wir haben noch eine kurze Hörerfrage. Christopher nochmal. Du wolltest ja wissen, warum, wenn die Transaktionen bei Bitcoin und Ethereum transparent sind, warum das sozusagen dann von Kriminellen gerne genutzt wird. Die Frage wurde eigentlich gerade schon beantwortet. Hast du es mitbekommen? Na ja, wir haben gerade darüber geredet, dass ja sozusagen in Bitcoin und Ethereum sozusagen keine Personen agieren, sondern in dieser Software, in diesen Blockchains, agieren immer nur Adressen.
Und diese Pseudonym.
Alledem geht es ja immer von irgendeiner IP aus.
Aber Bitcoin kann man auch über das Tornennetzwerk benutzen. Aber der Knackpunkt ist natürlich, irgendwann willst du deine Bitcoin in Euros oder in irgendwas anderes, was man in die Hand nehmen kann, irgendwie tauschen. Und dann gibt es einen, wie sagt man, Interface zur realen Welt, also eine Verbindung in die echte Welt. Und dann kann man dich ja doch wieder zurückverfolgen. Also man kann mit Bitcoin schon ein bisschen tricksen, aber man muss halt schon irgendwie aufpassen. Also wenn du sehr anonym bleiben willst, dann solltest du deine Bitcoins halt über Tor tauschen und das Geld dann mit irgendjemanden Unbekannten auf der Straße den Deal machen. Und nicht über Konten oder so.
Verständnisfrage, weil ist ja nun mal Fakt, dass die Währung natürlich nutzt wird. Aber großartig aus meiner Sicht passieren tut ja da echt nicht viel. Na ja, so wie ich verstanden bin, durch München jetzt erst würde Darknet mal wieder so ein bisschen eine Ohre, das ist neu, das ist Darknet.
Ja, aber das legt sich auch wieder.
Also Bitcoin ist nicht anonym, sondern pseudonym, wenn eine Verbindung zwischen der Bitcoin-Adresse und einer realen Person hergestellt wird, weil man die auf seiner eigenen Webseite veröffentlicht, zum Beispiel, oder weil man jemandem die sagt, dem man sie vielleicht nicht hätte sagen sollen, dann ist man identifizierbar mit dieser Adresse, wenn man selber die Verbindung herstellt.
Genau, aber man kann sozusagen, man kann sie sich dafür benutzen.
Unsere Hörer können ja mal zu blockchain.infosurfen, und da ist ein JavaScript oder was auch immer so ein Ticker programmiert. Da kann man jede einzelne Transaktion, die gerade im Bitcoin-Netzwerk passiert, die scrollt da so durch. Da kann man richtig live zugucken, was in diesem Bitcoin-Netzwerk gerade los ist, damit man ein Verständnis dafür hat, wie transparent das ist.
Okay, dann Christopher hoffe ich, wir konnten dir auch diese Frage noch beantworten. Dann viel Spaß noch. Und wir sind jetzt gleich schon am Ende der Sendung angekommen. Ich danke Dennis, Dirk und Christian, dass sie hier waren. Ich würde noch gerne wissen, ganz zum Schluss und ganz kurz, was wird eure präferierte Zahlungsmethode in 10 Jahren sein? Dennis?
Digital.
Na ja, digital, ach nee. Aber welche Form? Blockchain?
Das ist mir eigentlich fast wurscht. Hauptsache, es geht schnell und easy und ich muss nicht viel machen und man kann es mir nicht klauen.
Ich hoffe auf Zero Cash. Das wird dann tatsächlich anonyme Transaktionen ermöglichen, wenn es das hält, was es momentan für schon gibt.
Also Zero Cash ist ein konkretes Projekt.
Ja, da gibt es noch kein Mainnet zu, aber in zehn Jahren sind sie dann hoffentlich, ich hab jetzt schon seit fünf Jahren davon gehört, mal gucken, ob sie dann in zehn Jahren so weit sind.
Alles klar, Christian?
Ich bin jetzt dieses Zero Knowledge, von dem wir schon auch gesprochen haben.
Christian, wie willst du dein Eis bezahlen?
Eine Zahlungsmethode, bei der keine Daten über mich gesammelt werden können und die trotzdem schnell und praktisch ist.
Alles klar, wir werden dann sagen, in zehn Jahren an dieser Stelle vielleicht wieder drüber sprechen, womit wir gerade...
In zehn Jahren wollen wir alle Bargeld haben, gibt es nicht mehr.
Ich bin ja eh großer Fan von Shine. Vorerst wird es auch noch so bleiben. Liebe Gäste, ich danke euch, dass ihr so geduldig mit mir wart und alles schön erklärt habt. Liebe Hörer, ich danke fürs Zuhören. Wenn ihr es nochmal genau nachvollziehen wollt, auf fritz.de erscheint in dieser Nacht noch der Podcast. Wenig später auch mit Video auf chaosradio.ccc.de. Ansonsten könnt ihr im nächsten Monat in die Marienstraße 11 zum Chaos Computer Club kommen. Dort gibt es auch ein Chaos Radio, das nicht über Fritz gesendet wird. Da gibt es dann wieder in zwei Monaten eine Sendung. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter und mir bleibt nur noch eine Sache zu sagen, ne zwei. Die eine ist, jetzt gibt es gleich Gitarrenmusik mit Jan Schwarzkamp im Nightfly. Und die andere ist, lasst euch nicht überwachen und macht immer schön eure Backups. Don't forget I'm in your extended network, biatch!